Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. The audacious satellites of despotism, carrying fifteen centuries of pride and barbarism in their feudal souls, are now demanding in every land and from every throne the golden soldiers to reconquer the sceptre of France. You have shaken off the yoke of your despots, but surely this was not to bend the knee before a foreign tyrant. So now, led by the most sublime passions, beneath the trickler flag that you
谢谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。专制制度胆大妄为的卫星国，在其封建的灵魂中带着十五世纪的傲慢与野蛮，如今正在每个国家、向着每一张宝座索要黄金士兵，以夺回法兰西的权杖。你们已经摆脱了专制君主的枷锁，但此举绝不是为了在一个外国暴君面前屈膝。因此现在，在最崇高的热情的引领下，在你们
gloriously planted on the ruins of the Bastille, follow the course of your great destiny that beckons you on to the punishment of tyrants. Union et courage. Glory awaits you. Two arms, two arms. The honor and the salvation of the nation demand it. Two arms, two arms." So that, Dominicic was exceptionally rousing rhetoric, I think brilliantly ventriloquized by me, par moi. And it was Pierre Venio who was addressing the Legislative Assembly in Paris on the 3rd of January 1792. And what he was doing there was saying, let's have a crack at the Austrians.
光荣地插在巴士底狱废墟上的三色旗下，顺着召唤你们去惩罚暴君的伟大命运前行吧。团结与勇气。荣耀等待着你们。两只手臂，两只手臂。国家的荣誉与拯救需要它。两只手臂，两只手臂。”所以，多米尼克，这是极其激昂的修辞，我认为由我——也就是我本人——进行了一场精彩的腹语演绎。这是皮埃尔·韦尼奥于1792年1月3日在巴黎向立法议会发表的演讲。他当时在做的事情就是说，让我们去和奥地利人干上一仗。
He was indeed. So Venio was a brilliant speaker. Well, as listeners will be able to tell from that rendition. I mean, that was very rousing, Tom. If I were a Frenchman, I'd be on my feet. Should we go and invade Vienna? Right, exactly. So he was thought of as the best orator of the entire French revolution. The Cicero of the Republic. Yeah. We haven't mentioned him before, but he was one of the leading lights in a new
他确实如此。所以韦尼奥是一位出色的演说家。嗯，正如听众从刚才的朗诵中能听出来的那样。我的意思是，那非常激昂，汤姆。如果我是法国人，我早就站起来了。我们应该去攻打维也纳吗？没错，完全如此。因此，他被认为是整个法国大革命中最好的演说家。共和国的西塞罗。是的。我们以前没提到过他，但他是一个新
faction, which will appear in today's episode. Waves of factions, aren't they? Yeah, we've got so many factions. So they were called the Girondins and they're really the party of war. And this is going to be a transformative moment in this whole story and will change the course of the revolution completely, but not merely a transformative moment for the French Revolution. This is a transformative moment in world history because this is the beginning of a war that they all think, everybody thinks will be home by Christmas. And actually it lasts for almost 25 years off and on, totally
派系中的领军人物，这一派系将在今天的节目中登场。派系一波接一波，对吧？是的，我们有太多的派系了。所以他们被称为吉伦特派，他们实际上是战争党。这将是整个故事中的一个变革时刻，并将彻底改变革命的进程，但它不仅是法国大革命的变革时刻。这是世界历史上的一个变革时刻，因为这是一场战争的开始，所有人都认为——每个人都认为——他们会在圣诞节前回家。但实际上这场断断续续的战争持续了近25年，彻底
redraws the map of Europe and costs millions of lives. It's not just Europe actually, it's a genuine world war. So this is the road to Waterloo. It is the road to Waterloo. Yes. That's how we should brand this series. The road to Waterloo. And nobody in the assembly that day listening to Vennio speak has the slightest semblance of an inkling of what is coming.
重绘了欧洲地图，并造成了数百万人的死亡。这其实不仅限于欧洲，这是一场真正的世界大战。所以这是通往滑铁卢之路。这就是通往滑铁卢之路。是的。这就是我们应该为这个系列起的名字。通往滑铁卢之路。那天在议会里听韦尼奥演讲的没有一个人，哪怕有一丝一毫的预感，知道接下来会发生什么。
Because what people often think about the First World War, that people went to war with great enthusiasm and hurrah and let's do it, this is actually true of this, isn't it? There's great enthusiasm for it. Far more so. I mean, there's none of the foreboding that you have in the roads to the First World War. There is none of the sense of apocalyptic doom. Well, there is a sense of apocalypse, I think. A sense that good and evil will be engaged in a titanic confrontation and that the forces of good will triumph. And that is what is animating Berniou's language. I mean, he thinks of himself as a Cicero, but he is also absolutely part of that kind of apocalyptic Christian tradition.
因为人们对第一次世界大战通常的看法是，人们带着巨大的热情、欢呼和“让我们大干一场”的心态奔赴战场，这其实也适用于这场战争，对吧？人们对它有着巨大的热情。远比那更甚。我的意思是，通往第一次世界大战的道路上所具有的那种不祥预感，这里完全没有。那种末日降临的感觉也没有。不过，我想确实有一种末日感。一种善恶将在泰坦般的对抗中交锋、且正义的力量必将获胜的感觉。这就是维尼奥的语言所体现的精神。我的意思是，他自认为是西塞罗，但他也绝对属于那种末日基督教传统的一部分。
You're not wrong, Tom. You're never wrong when you bring out the, being part of a Christian continuity. Yeah, but it's the fusion of the classical and the Christian, I think, does so much to explain what makes this revolutionary tradition so instantaneously potent. Yeah, I think you're right. Talk about it being new and it is, the sense of novelty is part of the excitement, but it's a novelty that people have been conditioned to accept. So how do we get there?
你没说错，汤姆。每当你谈到基督教的延续性时，你从不会出错。是的，但我觉得古典传统与基督教传统的融合，在很大程度上解释了为什么这个革命传统会具有如此瞬间爆发的强大力量。是的，我觉得你说得对。说到它是崭新的——而且确实如此，这种新奇感是兴奋的一部分，但这也是人们已经被条件化所接受的新奇感。那么我们是如何走到这一步的呢？
How do we get to war? Well, remember where we ended last time. We ended on the 30th of September 1791. The constitution has been agreed. The National Assembly has met for the last time and gone home. And Louis has promised to knuckle down as a constitutional monarch, a promise that as everybody listening to these podcasts will know, he fully intends to break. Meanwhile, the great revolutionary club, the Jacobin club has split into two. The moderates have all walked out and set up their Foyant club under Antoine Barnard and his friends, who appear to be the people in charge. And that has left the Jacobemin as a kind of rump club and its big star is Maximilien Robespierre. So let's pick up straight
我们是如何走向战争的？好吧，还记得我们上次是在哪里结束的吗。我们的故事结束于1791年9月30日。宪法已经达成一致。国民议会召开了最后一次会议并解散回家了。路易承诺作为一名君主立宪制的君主痛改前非，正如所有收听这些播客的听众所知，这是一个他完全打算违背的承诺。与此同时，伟大的革命俱乐部——雅各宾俱乐部一分为二。温和派全部退场，在安东尼·巴纳夫及其朋友们的带领下成立了斐扬俱乐部，他们似乎成了掌权者。这使得雅各宾派变成了一个残缺的俱乐部，而它的超级巨星则是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔。所以让我们直接切入
away the new assembly voted for by sort of taxpayers, property owners meets for the first time at the beginning of October. So a 742 members and they're all new people because the old people have said they're not going to stand for the new assembly. So these people are even younger than their predecessors, even less experienced and more likely to not come from Paris but to come from small towns. Only a tiny fraction of them live in Paris. So they are outsiders. That's a bit of an obstacle when
由纳税人和业主之类的人投票选出的新议会在10月初召开第一次会议。总共有742名成员，而且他们全都是新人，因为老人已经说过他们不会竞选新议会。所以这些人比他们的前辈更年轻，经验更少，而且更有可能不是来自巴黎，而是来自小城镇。只有极小一部分人住在巴黎。所以他们是局外人。当
you're in the middle of this capital seething with tension. Another big handicap for them, they've only been elected by a tiny, tiny turnout. So there were sort of strict property thresholds for who could vote and the turnout anyway was terrible. So in some areas it was only 10%, 11% in Paris it was only 14%. So actually they have not got much of a mandate, you would say, not much of a popular mandate. So in they go and straight away the factionalism, you were kind of chuckling when I said we were about to introduce the Girondins as a new faction, the factionalism starts straight away. They arrange themselves very self-consciously. The radicals on the left, the more conservative on the right. This is obviously the French Revolution
你身处于这个充满紧张气氛的首都中心时，这算是一个障碍。对他们来说另一个巨大的不利条件是，他们是由极少极少的人投票选举产生的。因此，对于谁有投票权有着严格的财产门槛，而且投票率无论如何都很糟糕。所以在某些地区只有10%、11%，在巴黎只有14%的投票率。所以实际上你可以说他们没有多少合法性，没有多少民意授权。于是他们上台了，紧接着派系斗争——当我刚才说我们即将把吉伦特派引入为一个新派系时你还在咯咯笑——派系斗争立刻就开始了。他们非常刻意地排列了自己的座位。左翼是激进派，右翼是更保守的人。这显然是法国大革命中
the first time this has ever happened. About four out of ten of them, historians think, are Foyon, moderates who back Barnav and Co. Another four out of five are in the middle. People call them the plain because they sit in the bottom of their assembly and they can be swayed one way or the other. That leaves about two out of ten maximum who are radicals, members of the jacquemint club. The big difference is not one of background and social class and that stuff. It's actually kind of temperament and ideology. The Foyon think basically anarchy is very dangerous. The streets are dangerous. Moderation is all.
史无前例的事情。历史学家认为，其中大约十分之四是斐扬派，即支持巴纳夫等人的温和派。另外十分之四到五在中间。人们称他们为“平原派”，因为他们坐在议会的底部，可以随风倒。这就剩下最多大约十分之二是激进派，也就是雅各宾俱乐部的成员。巨大的差异不在于背景、社会阶层之类的事情。实际上是气质和意识形态的问题。斐扬派基本上认为无政府状态非常危险。街头很危险。温和至上。
And the Jacquemin think the common people are the incarnations of virtue. Poor people have wisdom and decency that richer people don't have. And we should embolden them and enfranchise them as much as possible. So they're populists. And this is a reversal of the traditional way of understanding things, isn't it? That it is wealth and education that brings you the expertise that enables you to run a government. And the Robespierre position, the radical Jacobin position, is that it's precisely the lack of that makes the poor more honest in a kind of Rousseauist manner.
而雅各宾派则认为普通民众是美德的化身。穷人拥有富人所没有的智慧和正义感。我们应该赋予他们勇气，并尽可能地赋予他们选举权。所以他们是民粹主义者。这颠覆了理解事物的传统方式，不是吗？即财富和教育带给你使你能够管理政府的专业知识。而罗伯斯庇尔的立场、激进的雅各宾派的立场则是，恰恰是这种缺乏，以一种卢梭式的方式使得穷人更加诚实。
They look into their souls and what is written on their souls is worth a million times what people have learned in salons and so on. So they've obviously got this from Rousseau and Rousseau obviously got it from a bloke in the Middle East in around about the turn of the reign of the Emperor Augustus. Didn't he, Tom? Is that correct? The last should be first and the first should be last and all that kind of business? Clearly, there are elements of that. So, there's this idealistic, I mean, they're all idealistic, by the way, in different ways. I mean, you could be a moderate or a radical, they're all pretty idealistic. But from the
他们审视自己的灵魂，写在他们灵魂上的东西比人们在沙龙等地方学到的东西价值高出百万倍。所以他们显然是从卢梭那里得到了这个启发，而卢梭显然是从中东的一个家伙那里得到了这个启发，大约在奥古斯都皇帝统治转折的时期。难道不是吗，汤姆？这正确吗？最后要成为最初的，最初要成为最后的，诸如此类的事务？显然，其中包含着这些元素。所以，存在着这种理想主义——顺便说一句，他们都是理想主义者，只是方式不同。我的意思是，无论你是温和派还是激进派，他们都相当理想主义。但从
moment they sit down, they're facing massive, massive challenges. I mean, France is in an absolute mess. Let's not underestimate that in the autumn of 1791. Half of the clergy are effectively in open defiance of the civil authorities because they have refused to swear this oath to the civil constitution of the clergy. Mass eruptions in the countryside, peasants refusing to pay their feudal dues to their seigneur and saying this is completely legitimate and attacking Chateau and destroying documents and things. Hard currency in France by this point has virtually disappeared and the French economy is afloat with paper money, which a lot of people find deeply suspicious and dodgy. I don't trust paper notes and they're called assignat and they are plummeting in value. So that means prices are going up. And classically traditions like that foster conspiracy theories, don't they? It's all
他们落座的那一刻起，他们就面临着巨大无比的挑战。我的意思是，1791年秋天的法国简直一团糟。我们不要低估这一点。半数神职人员实际上都在公然违抗民政当局，因为他们拒绝宣誓效忠《教士公民组织法》。乡村地区爆发大规模骚乱，农民拒绝向领主支付封建租税，称这是完全合法的，并攻击城堡、摧毁文件等等。此时法国的硬通货实际上已经消失了，法国经济靠纸币维持，许多人对此深表怀疑和不信任。我不信任纸币，它们被称为指券，而且它们的价值正在暴跌。这意味着物价正在上涨。经典地，这样的传统会滋生阴谋论，对吧？这一切
being manipulated by speculators, speculators and orders. So that's not helpful either. Not helpful at all. And in Paris, there was a growing sense of militancy and disorder because people can't afford to buy bread and people are angry and people have been kind of radicalised by the events of the last couple of years. And they have a sense that basically this new Legislative Assembly is meeting, but who gives a hoot about them? They don't really represent me anyway. So there's all that.
都是投机者、投机商和囤积者在操纵。所以这也毫无帮助。毫无帮助。在巴黎，激进主义和混乱的倾向日益加剧，因为人们买不起面包，人们很愤怒，人们在过去几年的事件中被某种程度上激进化了。他们有一种感觉，基本上是这个新的立法议会正在开会，但谁在乎他们呢？他们根本代表不了我。所以诸如此类的事情全都有。
Now, on top of that, there is something else we've mentioned last time, which is that when the Legislative Assembly meets, for the first time the news has actually arrived in France that the slaves on Saint-Domingue have launched a massive uprising in the richest colony empire this is a huge challenge for France for its economy but also as you said Tom what do you do if you've committed yourself to the rights of man, but at the same time, you believe in the rights of property and the importance of order. And you also believe in preserving the French economy.
现在，除此之外，还有我们在上次提到过的另一件事，那就是当立法议会召开时，法国第一次真正收到了这样的消息：圣多明哥的奴隶在帝国最富有的殖民这对法国及其经济构成了巨大的挑战，但正如你所说的，汤姆，如果你既致力于人权，但同时又相信财产权和秩序的重要性，你该怎么办？而且你还相信维护法国的经济。
So ideals and self-interest are rubbing up against each other very violently. And the other thing now, we love a ticking time bomb on the rest of history. And this is a ticking time bomb in human form. It's Marie Antoinette and Louis XVI who were determined to overthrow the revolution at the very first opportunity. I remember when I was doing this for A-level and one of the great essay questions was always, why didn't France settle down and have a constitutional monarchy like Britain? Why did the constitutional monarchy fail? I mean, if you're giving a really simple one sentence answer, the king never wanted it to work and would never have made it work.
因此，理想与自身利益正在发生非常激烈的摩擦。现在还有另一件事，我们“历史的其余部分”播客非常喜欢定时炸弹，而这就是一颗人类形态的定时炸弹。这就是玛丽·安托瓦内特和路易十六，他们决心在第一个机会到来时推翻革命。我记得我在准备A-Level（英国高中课程）考试时，其中一个伟大的论述题总是：为什么法国没有像英国那样稳定下来并实行君主立宪制？为什么君主立宪制失败了？我的意思是，如果你给出一个真正简单的一句话回答，那就是国王从来没想让它起作用，也从没打算让它起作用。
But just because you said in the previous episode that if he hadn't accepted this constitution, then they would have chucked him aside and they would have brought in his younger son, the Dov Fahim is about six. Why didn't they do that anyway? It would have made everything so much easier. Then that raises the problem of what do you do with him? You probably have to kill him. I suppose so. Yeah, I suppose.
但正如你在上一集所说的那样，如果他没有接受这部宪法，那么他们就会把他抛在一边，然后把他的小儿子——王储，大约六岁——扶上台。他们为什么不干脆那样做呢？那会让一切变得简单得多。这就引发了一个问题：你拿他怎么办？你大概得杀了他。我想是的。是的，我猜吧。
I guess you have to kill him because he will probably try to escape the country and raise an army to recapture his throne. I would guess. I mean, it's an interesting question. Had they done that, what would they have done with him then? Constant house arrest. That's presumably what you'd have to do with him. But you're absolutely right, Tom. Put him in an iron mask. In an iron mask. Yeah, why not? Perfect. No, so Louis and Marie Antoinette are just buying time, hoping that either the Revolution will fall apart or that the Austrians will intervene to save them. So in the story of that autumn
我猜你不得不杀了他，因为他很可能会试图逃离这个国家并组建军队来夺回他的王位。我猜会的。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的问题。如果他们真的那样做了，他们当时会对他做什么？长期软禁。这大概就是你不得不对他的所作所为。但你绝对是对的，汤姆。给他戴上铁面具。戴上铁面具。对，为什么不呢？完美。不，所以路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特只是在拖延时间，希望要么革命土崩瓦解，要么奥地利人介入来拯救他们。所以那个秋天的故事
is all these problems getting worse, much greater and greater rural disorder and the slave rebellion on Saint-Domingue getting further and further out of control. Thousands of people being killed, hundreds of plantations burned, the rebels are on their way to controlling almost half of the colony. And this is a massive threat to the French economy. And people start to see it in France, you know, I can't get coffee, I can't get sugar, the prices are going higher and higher and all of this kind of thing. So the moderate cause is actually, even though they appear to be the largest group, their position is eroding almost day by day and the Jacobin, the radical position is getting stronger. Now previously the radical spig star had been
就是所有这些问题变得更糟，农村的混乱程度越来越大，圣多明哥的奴隶叛乱越来越失控。数千人被杀，数百座种植园被焚毁，叛军即将控制近半个殖民地。这对法国经济构成了巨大威胁。人们开始在法国看到这一点，你知道的，我买不到咖啡，买不到糖，物价越来越高，诸如此类的事情。所以温和派的事业实际上——尽管他们看起来是最大的群体——他们的地位几乎在日复一日地被侵蚀，而雅各宾派、激进派的地位却越来越强大。此前，激进派的超级巨星一直是
Robespierre. We talked about him last time, but actually Robespierre, as soon as the National Assembly breaks up, he actually goes home. He goes back to Arras and there he's welcomed as a great hero, but he's away from Paris so he's out of the action. And so this whole business will be an absolute gift to a kind of Netflix. Cause they could use so many different actors and different character actors to come on at various points and seize the limelight. Cause now we have a new star, a really interesting character. He's a very admirable man, I think.
罗伯斯庇尔。我们上次谈到了他，但实际上罗伯斯庇尔一等国民议会解散，他就回家了。他回到了阿拉斯，在那里他受到英雄般的欢迎，但他远离巴黎，所以他没有参与行动。因此，整个事件对Netflix来说绝对是一份天赐的礼物。因为他们可以使用许多不同的演员和不同的性格演员在各个时间点登场并抢尽风头。因为现在我们有了一个新星，一个非常有趣的角色。我认为他是一个非常令人钦佩的人。
I said Rob Spier reminded me of you, but I mean, I think there's a lot of Tom Holland in this guy. Oh, well, thanks. I take that as a compliment. Well, we'll see whether it is a compliment. He's Jacques-Pierre Brisseau. I mean, not on the whole warmongering stuff. Yeah. So he's the son of a pastry cook from Chartres. He was a law clerk and he'd grown up in quite a lot of poverty because I think his parents had died or something like that. I can't remember.
我说过罗伯斯庇尔让我想起了你，但我的意思是，我觉得这家伙身上有很多汤姆·霍兰德的影子。哦，好吧，谢谢。我把这当作是赞美。好吧，我们拭目以待这究竟算不算赞美。他是雅克-皮埃尔·布里索。我的意思是，抛开所有好战的言论不谈。是的。所以他是沙特尔一个糕点师的儿子。他曾是一名法律文书学徒，在相当贫困的环境中长大，因为我记得他的父母好像去世了什么的。我记不清了。
Anyway, he'd been a law clerk and they became a hack writer, which turned out vampire novels and books on the Roman Republic. So he was writing travel books, but he also wrote a lot of pornography, like Stanley Baldwin actually. Yeah. And the Marquis de Sade of course. Yeah. So he traveled, Briceau in England and Switzerland and Belgium. He went to the US, as you'll be doing this autumn, Tom. He went to Boston. He wrote a three volume book about the new American Republic. He loved it. He said it was brilliant.
无论如何，他曾是一名法律文书学徒，后来成了一名靠码字为生的无名写手，批量炮制吸血鬼小说和关于罗马共和国的书籍。所以他写游记，但也写了很多色情作品，就像斯坦利·鲍德温一样。是的。当然还有萨德侯爵。是的。所以布里索游历了英国、瑞士和比利时。他去了美国，正如你今年秋天要去做的那样，汤姆。他去了波士顿。他写了一本关于新美洲共和国的三卷本书。他很喜欢它。他说这太棒了。
But he's also a very keen abolitionist. Massive. So this is something that he picks up in London and then I think on his travels. Yeah. Massive. He's very, very committed to the abolition of slavery. He set up a society, an international society called the Society of the Friends of the Blacks. That was what it was called. And this also, as we will see in our next episode, this also influences objection to capital punishment, which he's also against. He's a social justice activist.
但他也是一个非常热心的废奴主义者。极力主张。所以这是他在伦敦以及后来的旅行中领悟到的东西。是的。极力主张。他非常非常致力于废除奴隶制。他成立了一个协会，一个名为“黑人朋友之会”的国际协会。这就是它的名字。正如我们将在下一集中看到的，这也影响了他对死刑的反对，他也反对死刑。他是一位社会正义活动家。
I mean, that's what he is. He's a travelling writer and activist. And he threw himself into the revolution. He wasn't elected as a deputy. He was a journalist and a kind of activist behind the scenes. He has moved steadily leftward. So remember the petition from the last episode of the Chandon Massacre, it was Briceau who wrote the text of that petition. And finally, now he's been, it was Briso who wrote the text of that petition. And finally now he's been elected to the Legislative Assembly for the Department of the Sen. And he is a great star. Everybody, not everybody, but lots of people think he's brilliant. He loves a literary party, doesn't he?
我的意思是，他就是这样的人。他是一个游历各方的作家和活动家。他全身心地投入到革命中。他没有当选为代表。他是一个记者，也是幕后的一种活动家。他一直在坚定地向左转。所以还记得上一集中关于尚德马斯屠杀的请愿书吗，正是布里索撰写了那份请愿书的文本。最后，现在他被——正是布里索撰写了那份请愿书的文本。最后，现在他被选为塞纳省的立法议会议员。他是一颗巨星。每个人——也不是每个人，但许多人——都认为他太棒了他很喜欢文学聚会，对吧？
He does. That kind of thing, a salon. He's very self-confident. Even his friends said if you had one flaw, he was excessively confident. Now, Tom, you and I suffer from quite low self-esteem. We do. So we wouldn't get on with him at all. Although better help has been necessary with that, fortunately. Yeah, that's great news. And in fact, a problem for him is that he's so cosmopolitan and well
他确实如此。那种类型的聚会，沙龙。他非常自信。连他的朋友都说，如果你有一个缺点，那就是他过度自信。现在，汤姆，你和我都有着相当低的自尊感。我们确实有。所以我们根本和他合不来。不过幸运的是，为此寻求更好的帮助是很有必要的。是的，这是个好消息。事实上，他的一个问题是，他太见多识广、游历广泛且自信满满，以至于他可能会看不起像罗伯斯庇尔这样更具地方色彩的人并低估他们。而且他确实也没有真正庞大的平易近人的作风。所以，正如你所说的，他喜欢文学聚会。因此，他在这些聚会上闲逛的人是这个群体——吉伦特派。他总是喜欢聪明、自信的人。所以我们一开始提到的那个家伙，演说家韦尼奥，就是这些人之一。他们都来自波尔多，吉伦特省，这就是为什么他们被称为吉伦特派。
traveled and self-assured that he perhaps looks down on more provincial people like Robespierre and underestimates them. And he also doesn't really have a massive common touch. So he, as you said, he loves a literary party. So the people he hangs around with at these parties are this group, the Girondins. He always likes clever, confident people. So the guy we began with, Verniot, the orator, he's one of these people. They all have come from Bordeaux, the department of the Gironde, which is why they're called the Girondins.
而且他们每周两次喜欢去这个女人的文学沙龙。她在自己的公寓里举办晚宴。她叫马农·罗兰，罗兰夫人。她的丈夫罗兰——罗兰夫人。她的丈夫罗兰比她大得多，是他们这帮狐朋狗友之一。所以他是个工厂检查员，对吧？是的，其实有点无聊。但他对她忠心耿耿，正如我们将要看到的。
And they love going to this woman's literary salon twice a week. She has dinner in her apartment. She's called Manon Rolon, Madame Rolon. Her husband Rolon, Madame Roulon. Her husband Roulon, who's much older than she is, is one of their kind of cronies. So he's a factory inspector, isn't he? Yeah, he's a bit boring really. But he's devoted to her, as we will see.
我的意思是，他爱她爱到简直要命。他们去参加这些聚会，进行极其妙趣横生的交谈。这基本上就像《伦敦书评》、《卫报》书评版面或类似的东西。我当时还以为这就像《历史的其余部分》阿富汗期呢。当然是的，就是那种感觉。这就像我们精英俱乐部成员的聚会一样。我真不敢相信我当时没看到那个机会。这些人还有罗兰夫人，我认为他们非常准确地把握了1791年的时代精神，而斐扬派则没有。因为他们
I mean, he loves her literally to death. And they go to these parties and they have tremendously witty conversay. It's basically like the London review of books or the Guardian books pages or something. I was thinking it was like the rest of history, Afghanistan. Of course it is, that's what it's like. It's like the meetings of our elite club members. I can't believe I didn't see that opportunity. And these guys and Madame Roulon, they absolutely grasp I think the mood of the moment in 1791 in a way that the foil do not. Because what they
看到的是，政治生活已经彻底改变，恐惧和怀疑的气候现在已经完全根深蒂固。所以我们之前提到了历史学家蒂莫西·塔凯特。他说，基本上在整个政治光谱中，现在广泛存在着一种关于整体宏大阴谋的信念，即内部阴谋分子、外部阴谋分子、宫廷中的阴谋分子都在同心协力，而且有人在幕后操纵。大体上，人们认为幕后操纵的人或群体是玛丽·安托瓦内特和奥地利皇帝，他们在控制着这一切。现在，这正是法国政治中那种唾手可得的机会，而斐扬派却无法利用这一点。你能利用唾手可得的机会吗？我的隐喻用得糟糕透顶，但他们无法利用这一点，因为他们和国王太亲近了。他们已经把自己的命运和国王绑在了一起。但布里索本质上是个共和主义者，他可以利用这一点，而且他决心这样做。他有一个非常狡猾的策略，对吧？这是一个非常狡猾的策略。他将削弱君主制。他会迫使国王暴露自己，而且他手头有完美的议题。这就是这些人的议题，也就是流亡者。所以我们承诺过要谈论他们。因此，在我对这种HBO风格剧集的想象中，
see is that political life has radically changed and that a climate of fear and suspicion has now become completely ingrained. So we mentioned the historian Timothy Tackett before. He says, basically across the political spectrum, there is now a widespread belief in a monolithic grand conspiracy, where internal conspirators, there is now a widespread belief in a monolithic grand conspiracy, where internal conspirators, external conspirators, conspirators in the court are all working together, and somebody is pulling the strings. And by and large, people think that the person pulling the strings or the people are Marie Antoinette and the Austrian emperor, and that they're controlling the whole thing. Now, that is the kind of open
在我对这种HBO风格剧集的想象中，这就是镜头从巴黎倾盆大雨切换到阳光普照的莱茵河的时刻。我更倾向于再次出现一个有非常非常精致的瓷杯装着热巧克力的沙龙，诸如此类的情景。真的吗？男仆。是的，因为你有热巧克力，而在我的脑海里，这就是我加入无故裸露镜头的地方。哦，真的吗？我会让流亡的王子们在莱茵河畔与村姑们嬉戏狂欢。我就会这么做。他们当时真的是在干这个吗？不是，但你必须允许自己有一点戏剧创作的自由，我想，这样它才能成为一部热门剧集。我想雅各宾激进派正在实行自由恋爱，不是吗？不，他们是以一种非常刻板的方式在谈论卢梭。这就是我觉得他们在做的事情。但在Netflix的剧集里。我想是的，也许吧。无论如何，流亡者。所以第一个离开的流亡者实际上是路易极其反动的弟弟——阿图瓦伯爵查理。他早就走了。立刻就走了，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为就在巴士底狱事件之后不久。就在巴士底狱事件之后不久。一些人加入了他的行列，然后一直有稳定的小股人员加入。到1791年，他已经在莱茵兰特里尔选帝侯辖区的科布伦茨安顿下来。所以尽管人们可能会说，天啊，革命者是带着阴谋论的可怕人物，但他完全是公开的。我要策划一个阴谋来推翻革命。我要屠杀大量的人。是的。所以他的目标是——而且他已经说过——如果他能回到巴黎，他会让巴黎笼罩在恐怖的阴影之下。
goal of French politics and the foyon can't play on that. Can you play on an open goal? I'm mixing my metaphors horrendously, but they can't exploit that because they're so close to the king. They're thrown in their lot with him. But Briceau, who is really a Republican, he can play on it and he's determined to do it. And he has a very cunning strategy, doesn't he? It's a very cunning strategy. He will undermine the monarchy. He'll force the king to expose himself and he's got the perfect issue. And this is the issue of these people, the emigres. So we promised we'd talk about them. So in my imagination of this kind of HBO series,
我的意思是，他对此完全直言不讳。这倒也算他敢作敢当。到1791年，他的另一个兄弟——普罗旺斯伯爵路易·斯坦尼斯拉斯也加入了他的行列（顺便说一句，查理和路易·斯坦尼斯拉斯最终都成了法国国王），还有他们的亲戚孔代亲王。所以他们都在那儿。还有一个人们可能从第一季早期节目中记得的家伙，夏尔-亚历山大·德·卡洛讷。所以卡洛讷，那个财政大臣，同时也是个股票经纪人，因为把自己弄得大发横财而遭到所有人的憎恨。他也在那里，基本上充当他们的首相，并且已经开始与欧洲列强展开会谈，你知道的，我们有没有什么办法能让你们资助一场对法国的大规模入侵？好吧，他当时直接去了伦敦，对吧？最初流亡的时候，然后他最终落脚回到了低地国家。完全正确。所以问题是，他们都在那里，就在边界的那一边。现在，他们是一个严重的威胁吗？简短的回答是，不，他们根本不是。因为实际上，尽管有1,0000人离开了，但其中许多人是妇女和儿童，
we talk about them. So in my imagination of this kind of HBO series, this is the moment when it cuts from the kind of the pouring rain of Paris to the sun-kissed rhino. I was thinking more a salon again with very, very kind of Shinse cups of chocolate, that kind of thing. Really? Footman. Yeah, because you've got cups of chocolate, whereas in my mind, This is where I put in the gratuitous nudity. Oh really? I'd have emigre princes cavorting with Rhineland wenches. That's what I would do. Is that what they were getting up to? No, but it's you've got to allow yourself a
他们只有一支大约4,000人的军队。我的意思是，这显然是可怜巴巴的。这离你在巴黎街头发动恐怖统治所需的规模差得十万八千里。不过，多米尼克，有一件事需要牢记，考虑到接下来要发生的事情，这一点很重要：军队中的军官阶层，要么军官们已经去加入了这个流亡宫廷，要么他们正在考虑这么做。对于巴黎那些精通军事事务的人来说，这表明实际上法国的军事资源并非处于最佳状态。
little bit of dramatic license, I think, for it to be a hit series. I think Jacobin radicals are engaging in free love aren't they? No, they're talking about Russo in a very pinched way. That's what I think they're doing. But in a Netflix series. I guess so, maybe. Anyway, the exiles. So the first exile really to leave was Louis's incredibly reactionary younger brother, Charles, the Count of Artois. He had gone off. Straight away, hadn't he? I mean, I think immediately after the Bastille. Immediately after the Bastille. And a few people had joined him and there'd been a
哦，是的，因为我的意思是，我们知道人们自己不一定清楚这一点，但汤姆，你和我都知道，法国军队已经陷入了彻底的混乱。人们不服从军官的指挥，而且许多高级军官正如你刚才所说，他们已经去了科布伦茨，或者正准备去，因为他们对革命当局已经失去了所有的信心。我的意思是，如果真的爆发战争，这将是一个巨大的问题。这就是为什么我只是在想，我的意思是，你知道的，你刚才说他们不是威胁，
steady kind of trickle. And by 1791, he has installed himself in Koblenz, which is in the electorate of Trier in the Rhineland. So for all that people may say, gosh, the revolutionary is terrible people with their conspiracy theories, he is totally open. I'm going to run a conspiracy to overthrow the revolution. And I'm going to massacre large numbers of people. Yeah. So his aim is, and he said this, that if he gets back to Paris, he will subject Paris to the shadow of a terror.
但实际上拥有大约1,0000名训练有素、相当富有、并且有着极其明确目标的流亡人员，去对抗一支本质上正在变成乌合之众的军队。我的意思是，胜算可能比表面看起来要稍具威胁性一些。我认为这并非完全不公允。而且你也说的对，还有其他原因，比表面看起来要稍具威胁性一些。是的。你不觉得吗？比它们看起来要显得更具威胁性。我认为这并非完全不公允。而且你也说的对，还有其他原因导致法国人会在心中把流亡者的威胁夸大。
Yeah. I mean, he's absolutely up front about it. Fair play to him. He has been joined by 1791 by his brother Louis Stanislas, Count of Provence, both Charles and Louis Stanislas, by the way, who eventually become King of France and their relative, the Proust Condé. So they're there. Also there is a guy that people may remember from the early days of season one, Charles-Alexandre de Calon. So Calon, the finance minister who was also a stockbroker and everybody hated because he'd made himself so rich. He's there and he's basically
所以首先，他们认为流亡者要对经济困境负责。他们说是流亡者的货币投机毁掉了我们纸币的价值，并推高了通货膨胀。这全都是他们的错。没错。所以我们讨论过这个，不是吗？那就是恶性通货膨胀和货币贬值总是会产生这些阴谋论。流亡者所扮演的角色，就像犹太人在比如魏玛德国所扮演的角色一样。是的，完全正确。接下来，激进派报纸说这些人要入侵我们的城市，强暴我们所有的妇女，谋杀我们的孩子。这就是将要发生的事情。你知道的，这其中有一丝真相。如果他们真的入侵了法国，正如你自己所说的，
their prime minister and he has opened talks with the European powers, you know, is there some way that we can get you to finance a big invasion of France? Well, he'd gone straight to London, hadn't he? Initially, when he goes into exile and then he kind of ends up back in the lowland. Exactly. So the question is, you know, there they all are, just over the border. Now, are they a serious threat? And the short answer is, no, they're not at all. Because actually, even though 10,000 people have left, a lot of those are women and children,
阿图瓦伯爵对此是毫不隐瞒的。你知道的，他迫不及待地想对巴黎人民大开杀戒。而且即使你是一个温和派政治家，他们待在这些德国小邦国里也着实是一种耻辱。所以有些人在科布伦茨，有些人在美因茨。这些小选帝侯国基本上在庇护流亡集团。世界上没有任何一个国家会对此无动于衷。我的意思是，如果英国也是如此，如果卢森堡在庇护英国流亡者，就像——现在哪里是圣莫尼卡玛丽布正在庇护一个英国流亡者，汤姆？一个流亡王子。
they only have an army of about 4,000 people. I mean, that is obviously pitiful. That's nowhere near what you need to launch a terror in the streets of Paris. But Dominic, one thing to bear in mind, and this is important considering what's going to come, the officer class in the army, either officers have gone to join this court in exile, or they are thinking about it. And so that suggests for people in the know about military affairs in Paris, that actually France's military resources are not all they could be.
一个流亡王子。是的。我的意思是，想想他得到的媒体关注。难怪布里索一直在打流亡者这张牌。而且他非常擅长把这一切拼凑起来。他说，看，这是一幅拼图，你把所有的碎片拼在一起，画面就非常清晰了。他说，存在一个网络。它由一个奥地利委员会运营。玛丽·安托瓦内特是他们某种程度上的法国联络人。她在把巴纳夫和斐扬派当成她的提线木偶。她在维也纳的哥哥利奥波德是另一个大Boss，他在把莱茵兰的流亡者当作他的提线木偶，这一切都是连在一起的，它解释了一切。这就是为什么关于玛丽·安托瓦内特
Oh yeah, because I mean we know that people don't necessarily know this themselves, but Tom you and I know that the don't necessarily know this themselves, but Tom you and I know that the French army has descended into total chaos. People are disobeying their officers and a lot of the officers, the senior officers, as you just said, they have gone to Koblenz or they are preparing to go because they have lost all confidence in the revolutionary authorities. I mean that's going to be a massive problem if it comes to a war. So that's why I'm just wondering, I mean, you know, you're saying that they're not a threat,
具有乱伦倾向的色情传统会产生如此强烈的共鸣的原因。那种她从小与兄弟进行乱伦的想法。当然，因为他们不仅仅是姐弟（兄妹）。他们是一对阴险的夫妇。我的意思是，这正是这一切的核心所在。因此，到1791年秋天，布里索、韦尼奥和他们的朋友们说，是时候对这些人在法国的盟友进行大规模打击了。当然，他们计划的天才之处在于，根据宪法，他们得以通过
but actually to have kind of 10,000 people who are very well trained, quite wealthy, have a very precise object in view up against an army that is essentially becoming a rabble. I mean, it's the odds are maybe slightly more menacing than they might otherwise seem. I think that's not necessarily unfair. And you're also right that there are other reasons slightly more menacing than they might otherwise seem. Yeah. Don't you think? Than they might seem. I think that's not necessarily unfair. And you're also right that there are other reasons why people in France, they sort of big the emigres up in their minds about what a threat they are.
立法，但随后国王必须决定是否否决它。他们知道国王会否决他们的所作所为，而这会暴露他是敌人阴谋的一部分。因此，在1791年11月，他们推出了两项法律，这两项法律都旨在让路易根本无法接受。其中一项是对那些尚未签署效忠新政权协议的剩余神职人员进行大规模打击。如果他们不签署，他们将失去养老金以及行使圣礼的权利，并且他们面临着被宣布为祖国（patrie）敌人的风险。路易当然立刻否决了这一点，
So first of all, they think the emigres are responsible for the plight of the economy. They say it's the emigres whose currency speculations have destroyed the value of our paper money and is driving up inflation. That's all their fault. Right. So we talked about this, didn't we? That yeah, hyperinflation and currency money losing its value always generates these conspiracy theories. And it's the emigres who are playing the role that Jews often play in, say, Weimar Germany. Yeah, absolutely right. Next, the radical papers say these guys are going to invade our cities, rape all our women, murder our children. This is what's going to happen. And you know, there is a grain of truth in that. If they did invade France, you said yourself,
这在法国各地引发了骚乱，包括里昂、马赛和巴黎等等。第二部分立法。他们说不返回巴黎的流亡者将被宣布为逃犯（outlaw），他们的财产将被没收，如果我们抓住他们，他们将面临死刑。顺便说一句，这特别包括国王的兄弟们。当然，国王绝不可能同意这一点。正如每个人所知的那样，他否决了它。这对国王来说是一场公关灾难。他为什么不直接签了呢？如果我是设身处地为他着想，在那种情况下我会签署，因为我本来就是一个绝对的撒谎精。我在左中右到处说谎。我想我也不妨再多说一个谎。而且我希望这个谎言会如此明显，以至于它能作为一种信号传达给我的兄弟们和其他皇室家庭，即——你知道的，
the Conte d'Atoire was absolutely open about it. You know, he can't wait to get stuck into the people of Paris. And even if you're a moderate politician, it's kind of humiliating that they're there in these tiny little German states. So there's some in Koblenz, there's some in Mainz. These little electorates are basically harbouring exile groups. There is no country in the world that would look on that with equanimity. I mean, if that was the case in Britain, if Luxembourg was harbouring British exiles, as where is it Malibu Santa Monica is currently harbouring a British exile Tom? An emigre prince.
我陷入了绝境，我是被迫这么做的。这就像某种人质留下的信息。是的，你或许可以这么做，我猜。路易是个相当固执的人。他不狡猾。而且他也是个白痴，不是吗？他是个白痴。你知道谁会签署这个吗？
An emigre prince. Yeah. I mean, think about the press he gets. So it's no wonder that Briso is playing the emigre card all the time. and he is brilliant at putting all this together. He says, look, it's a jigsaw and you put all the pieces together and the picture is perfectly clear. He says, there is a network. It's run by an Austrian committee. Marie Antoinette is their kind of French contact. She's using Barnav and the Foyant as her puppets. Her brother Leopold in Vienna is the other big Gs and he is using the Rhineland exiles as his puppets and it all connects and it explains everything. And this is why the pornographic traditions about Marie Antoinette
查理二世。他会毫不犹豫地签了。查理——谁会签这个？查理二世。他会毫不犹豫地签了，甚至在他们起草之前就会签。他会相当乐意摆脱詹姆斯，不是吗？但查理二世绝对会——你知道的，政治领导力和战术技巧很重要，而查理二世——愤世嫉俗、善于盘算，所有这些东西——他会觉得这真的很棘手，但你完全可以想象他通过谈判摆脱了困境。路易此时已经很胖了，不是吗？他简直是个白痴。我的意思是，这显然是一个陷阱。这就好象，这里有一个巨大的大象陷阱。哦，是吗？那我走进去吧。他没救了。他只是在跌跌撞撞。他根本不在状态。他把所有时间都花在吃喝上。他非常幻灭并且沮丧。他只是一副“我才不管这破事”的样子，而且他根本没有未雨绸缪。
being incestuous are so resonant. The idea that she had grown up committing incest with her brothers. Of course, because they're not just brother and sister. They're a sinister couple. I mean, that lies at the center of all this. So by the autumn of 1791, Briceau, Verneau and their friends say, it's time for a massive crackdown on these people and their allies in France. And of course the genius of their plan is under the constitution, they get to pass
我也觉得，另一件事，汤姆，实际上，他和玛丽·安托瓦内特被他们自己的政治偏见蒙蔽了双眼。他们仍然认为革命会土崩瓦解。所以在某种程度上，他只是觉得这无关紧要。我觉得他从未真正意识到局势的极端性。再次强调，这是一种政治想象力的匮乏，不是吗？政治想象力的彻底匮乏。我不能同意你更多了。我认为他缺乏政治想象力可能他在众多缺陷中最大的一项。无论如何，这不仅是对君主制的巨大打击，当然也是对支持斐扬派、温和派的人的巨大打击，因为这看起来他们好像是同一个阴谋的一部分。长话短说，这意味着随着我们来到1791年12月，新立法议会中的权力平衡已经发生了转变。布里索——你所喜爱的这位社会正义活动家——现在占据了绝对的上风和势头。现在他可以施压要求他真正想要的东西了，汤姆，那就是战争。
legislation, but then the king has to decide whether or not to veto it. They know that the king will veto what they do and that that will expose him as part of the enemy conspiracy. So in November 1791, they introduced two laws that are both designed to be impossible for Louis to accept. One is a massive crackdown on those remaining priests who have not signed up to the new regime. They will lose their pensions and indeed their right to administer the sacraments if they don't sign up and they risk being declared enemies of the homeland, of the patrie. Louis immediately vetoes this of course and
立法，但接着国王必须决定是否行使否决权。他们知道国王会否决他们的行动，而这会暴露他是敌对阴谋的一部分。因此，在1791年11月，他们推出了两项法律，其设计都让路易绝对无法接受。一项是对那些尚未签署效忠新政权的留任神职人员进行大规模打压。如果他们不签署，将失去养老金以及主持圣礼的权利，并面临被宣布为祖国（即法兰西祖国）敌人的风险。路易当然立刻否决了这一点，并且
that sets off riots across France and Lyon, Marseille and Paris and so on. Legislation bit number two. They say emigres who don't return to Paris will be declared outlaws, their property will be confiscated and they will face the death penalty if we catch them. And by the way, this specifically includes the King's brothers. Of course, there's no way the King is going to agree to this. He vetoes it as everybody knows he will. And that is a PR disaster for the king. Why couldn't he have done it? If I was trying to signal, I think in his situation, I would have signed it because I'm already an absolute fibber. I'm telling lies left, right and center. I think I might as well tell another one. And I'd hope that the lie would be so obvious that it would serve as a signal to my brothers and to other Royal households that, um, you know, I'm in an
这在整个法国以及里昂、马赛和巴黎等地引发了骚乱。第二项立法部分。他们宣布不返回巴黎的流亡贵族将被宣判为逃犯，其财产将被没收，如果我们抓住他们，他们将面临死刑。顺便说一句，这特别包括国王的兄弟们。当然，国王绝不可能同意这一点。正如所有人所料，他否决了。这对国王来说是一场公关灾难。他为什么不能签字呢？如果我是他，在那种情况下，我想我会签署的，因为我本来就是个彻头彻尾的骗子。我在左中右到处撒谎。我想我也不介意再多撒一个。我希望这个谎言能如此明显，以至于能向我的兄弟们和其他王室传达这样一个信号：呃，你知道的，我陷入了
absolute hole, I'm being forced to do this. It's like kind of hostage message. Yeah, you could do, I guess. Louis is quite stubborn man. He's not crafty. He's also an idiot, isn't he? He's an idiot. You know who would have signed this?
绝对的绝境，我被逼无奈才这么做的。这就像是一种人质留下的信息。是的，你或许可以这么做。路易是个相当顽固的人。他不狡猾。他也是个白痴，不是吗？他是个白痴。你知道谁会签这个吗？
Charles the second. He would like a, like a bullet. Charles the who would have signed this? Charles II. He would have, like a bullet. Charles II would have signed it even before they drafted it. He'd be quite relieved to get rid of James, wouldn't he? But Charles II would have absolutely, you know, political leadership and tactical skill matters. And Charles II, cynical, calculating, all of that stuff. He would have found this really tricky, but you could well
查理二世。他会像子弹一样……谁会签这个？查理二世。他会像子弹一样。查理二世甚至在他们起草之前就会签了。摆脱詹姆斯会让他感到相当宽慰吧？但查理二世绝对会……你知道，政治领导力和战术技巧至关重要。而查理二世，愤世嫉俗、精于算计，诸如此类。他会觉得这真的很棘手，但你完全可以
imagine him negotiating his way out of it. Louis is very fat at this point, isn't he? He's just an idiot. I mean, this is so obviously a trap. It's like, here's a large elephant trap. Oh, is it? I'll walk into it. He's hopeless. He's just blundering. He's not really on the ball. He's spending all his time eating and drinking. He's very disillusioned and depressed. He's just like, I'm not going to do this. And he's not really thinking ahead.
想象他设法通过谈判摆脱困境。路易在这个时候非常胖，不是吗？他简直就是个白痴。我的意思是，这显然是个陷阱。这就好比，看，这里有个巨大的大象陷阱。哦，是吗？那我走进去吧。他无可救药了。他只是在糊涂行事。他根本不在状态。他把所有时间都花在吃喝上了。他非常幻灭和沮丧。他只是觉得，我才不管呢。他根本没有长远考虑。
I think as well, the other thing, Tom, actually, he and Marion Tornette are so blinded by their own political prejudices. They still think the revolution will fall apart. So in a way he just thinks it doesn't matter. I don't think he ever quite realizes the extremity of the position. Again, well that's a failure of political imagination, isn't it? Total failure of political imagination. I couldn't agree with you more. I think his lack of political imagination is probably the single biggest defect that he has out
我也认为，汤姆，还有一件事，实际上，他和玛丽·安托瓦内特被他们自己的政治偏见蒙蔽了双眼。他们仍然认为革命会自行瓦解。所以在某种程度上，他只是觉得这无所谓。我不认为他真正意识到了局势的极端性。话说回来，这也是政治想象力的缺失，不是吗？政治想象力的彻底缺失。我不能同意你更多了。我认为他缺乏政治想象力可能是他在诸多缺陷中
of many. Anyway, this is a massive vote, not just to the monarchy, but of course to the people who support the foillon, the moderates, because it looks like they're kind of part of the same conspiracy. And to cut a very long story short, what this means is as we get to December 1791, the balance of power has shifted in the new legislative assembly. Riso, social justice activist who you love, now has very much the upper hand and the momentum. And now he can press for the thing that he really wants. And that Tom is war.
最严重的一个。无论如何，这不仅是对君主制的巨大打击，当然也是对支持斐扬派（温和派）的人的巨大打击，因为这看起来他们似乎也是同一个阴谋的一部分。简而言之，这意味着到了1791年12月，新立法议会的权力平衡已经发生了转变。里索，你深爱的那个社会活动家，现在占据了绝对的上风和强劲势头。现在他可以极力推动他真正想要的东西了。而汤姆，那就是战争。
Right. So let's take a break. And when we come back, it's war. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we Hello and welcome back to The Rest Is History and Dominic, c'est la guerre. War is approaching, but why and how and wither and wherefore and whence? So Tom, you could argue, I think reasonably, that the idea for war has been implicit in
没问题。那么我们休息一下。回来之后，我们将迎来战争。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐剩下的事》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，我们 Hello，欢迎回到《历史剩下的事》与多米尼克，c'est la guerre。战争即将来临，但为什么、如何、去往何方、因何而起、又从何而来？因此，汤姆，你可以合乎情理地认为，战争的观念其实从一开始就隐含在
the revolution from the very beginning. So first of all, France is a state built for war. I mean, France is a state that's always fighting wars. So it's actually the only global superpower with an army and a Navy. Britain, of course, has a Navy, but it doesn't have much of an army. Austria and Prussia have armies, but no real Navy. And France has always seen itself as being in this great global competition. So France is set up to fight wars. It's what France does.
这场革命之中。首先，法国是一个为战争而打造的国家。我的意思是，法国是一个一直在打仗的国家。所以它实际上是唯一一个既有陆军又有海军的全球超级大国。英国当然有海军，但它没有什么陆军。奥地利和普鲁士有陆军，但没有真正的海军。法国一直把自己视为这场伟大全球竞争的参与者。因此，法国天生就是为了打仗而建立的。这就是法国所做的事，
It's what France is really good at. Although that is kind of what contributed to the revolution. Of course. But I don't think anybody says, oh, therefore we should fight fewer wars. They think we should fight more wars more successfully. Yeah, of course. Now I think another element of this is the revolution is always a universalist mission. So you talked about that in your episode in season one about the ideas.
这也是法国真正擅长的事情。尽管这在某种程度上也促成了革命的爆发。当然。但我认为没有人会说“哦，因此我们应该减少战争”。他们认为我们应该更成功地打更多仗。对，当然。现在我认为其中的另一个要素是，革命永远是一项普世主义的使命。所以你在第一季关于思想的那集节目里谈到过这一点。
And it's quite convenient, isn't it? If you want to go and conquer foreign countries, if you feel that you're doing it on the side of right. If you're fighting on the side of Liberty against the tyrants who have enslaved you, I mean, that is the ethos of the revolution. From the very outset, there is this kind of crusading spirit. And as you said, people have been primed for this by centuries of Christian ideology. The revolution is absolutely part of that. But equally significantly, I think, again, very much plain to you, revolutionists feel themselves the heirs of Republican Rome. And they think that healthy societies are instilled with the spirit of kind of patriotic sacrifice.
而且这相当方便，不是吗？如果你想去征服外国，如果你觉得你是站在正义的一边。如果你是为自由而战，对抗那些将你奴役的暴君，我的意思是，这就是革命的精神内核。从一开始，就有一种类似十字军东征的精神。正如你所说，几个世纪以来的基督教意识形态已经为人们做好了这种心理铺垫。革命绝对是其中的一部分。但同样重要的是，我认为，再次重申，非常显而易见的是，革命者把自己视为罗马共和国的继承人。他们认为健康的社会都注入了一种爱国牺牲的精神。
Because they're now citizens in the way that the Romans were citizens and that you best manifest your sense of citizenship by standing together in war. I mean, that's the Roman understanding and it's one that is obviously very fertile in terms of where France is with the revolution at this point. Yeah, I think absolutely. It's kind of a masculinity thing as well, isn't it? My take on this is that that makes the French Revolution exceptional from the very beginning because it's obviously different from the revolution in England in the 1640s and 1650s. There was never really any expectation that that would be exported by force of arms.
因为他们现在成为了公民，就像罗马人曾经是公民那样，而你展现公民意识的最佳方式就是在战争中并肩作战。我的意思是，这就是罗马人的理解，而且在法国目前处于革命的这个阶段，这种理解显然是非常具有催生作用的。是的，我绝对这么认为。这在某种程度上也关乎男子气概，不是吗？我对这件事的看法是，这使得法国大革命从一开始就具有独特性，因为它显然不同于1740年代和1650年代的英国革命。当时从来没有任何人期望通过武力将那场革命输出到海外。
Well, it kind of is, isn't it? It kind of is to Ireland. To Ireland, but not to continental Europe. There's no sense that Cromwell is going to be leading armies rampaging through central Europe. Well, Jamaica. So the Jamaican expedition against Spain, there is a kind of sense that they are up against, you know, the evils of Catholicism.
好吧，其实某种程度上是的，不是吗？对爱尔兰来说算是一种输出。对爱尔兰是这样，但对欧洲大陆则不然。当时没有任何人觉得克伦威尔会率领大军在欧洲中部横冲直撞。好吧，牙买加。因此，针对西班牙的牙买加远征，确实有一种感觉，即他们正在对抗，你知道的，天主教的邪恶。
But very limited compared with what comes. The French Revolution, the French Revolution is spilling over beyond its borders from the very outset. I mean, that is why Burke and Payne, Edmund Burke and Thomas Payne are having this war of words about the meaning of the French Revolution. It's why in 1791 in the summer on Bastille Day, so we began the last episode, Bastille Day 1791, if we'd begun that episode in Birmingham, Tom, there would have been riots and an inferno as people attacked Joseph Priest's house and they attack dissenting chapels because they say because of these sort of lefty free thinkers, the French Revolution is going to erupt any minute here in the West Midlands.
但与后来发生的相比，这非常有限。法国大革命，法国大革命从一开始就溢出了它的国界。我的意思是，这就是为什么伯克和潘恩——埃德蒙·伯克和托马斯·潘恩——会就法国大革命的意义展开这场文字之战的原因。这就是为什么在1791年夏天的攻占巴士底狱日——所以我们在上一集节目开始时讲到了1791年的攻占巴士底狱日——如果我们把那一集的开场放在伯明翰，汤姆，那里的情况将是一场骚乱和炼狱，人们袭击约瑟夫·普里斯特利的住宅，袭击异见教堂，因为他们说，由于这些所谓的左翼自由思想家，法国大革命随时都可能在西米德兰兹郡爆发。
Well, again, it's that association with kind of radical Protestantism. Exactly. But it anticipates, obviously, the fears of the Russian Revolution in the 1920s, that it's an international conspiracy that is poised to erupt beyond France's boundaries. And actually, the first moment that that happens, until I'd read up on this, it had never actually occurred to me. Even before war was declared, this has already happened. It happened in September 1491 in Avignon. Yeah is a Papal territory, which wasn't part of France. I had completely overlooked this until I was reading up on it. And it's very Russia in Crimea in 2014.
好吧，这同样是与那种激进新教主义的联系。完全正确。但它显然预示了20世纪20年代人们对俄国革命的恐惧，即这是一场蓄势待发、准备突破法国国界的国际阴谋。事实上，在发生这种情况的最初时刻——在我阅读相关资料之前，我从未真正想到过这一点。甚至在宣战之前，这一切就已经发生了。它发生在1491年9月的阿维尼翁。是的，这是一个教皇领地，它不属于法国。在我查阅资料之前，我完全忽略了这一点。这非常类似于2014年俄罗斯在克里米亚的行动。
The revolutionaries organise a referendum in Avignon, and it is the little green men or whatever they called them in the Crimea, going around, people up. There's a lot of violence, there's a lot of intimidation. And then a month after this referendum, after the French have basically annexed Avignon, there was a load of violence erupts. People protest against the annexation. They say the Virgin Mary is weeping because she's so sad at the kind of sacrilege of the... The Pope has lost his... Yeah.... his territory. And these women, having seen the Virgin Mary weeping, they're like, well, we should do something about this.
革命者在阿维尼翁组织了一场公投，就像克里米亚那些被称为“绿衣小人”或类似称呼的人四处游说一样。当时有大量的暴力活动，大量的恐吓。然后在这场公投的一个月后，在法国基本上吞并了阿维尼翁之后，爆发了大量的暴力冲突。人们抗议吞并行为。他们说圣母玛利亚在哭泣，因为她对这种亵渎的行为感到如此悲伤……教皇失去了他的……是的……他的领土。这些妇女看到圣母玛利亚在哭泣后，她们心想，好吧，我们得做点什么。
They get this bloke who's a leading Jacobin. They beat him over the head with paving stones and they shove knitting needles in his eyes. But in retribution, the local Jacobin round up all these women and their friends. They kill 60 of them, beat them to death with iron bars and then they throw their bodies down the toilet of the palace. So it's very poor behaviour on all sides, Tom, I think it's fair to say. And the revolutionary government in Paris gives the Chacabas all a blanket pardon. They've been the real victims in this.
她们找了一个雅各宾派的骨干分子。她们用铺路石猛砸他的头部，把织毛衣的针戳进他的眼睛里。作为报复，当地的雅各宾派把这些妇女和她们的朋友全部抓了起来。他们杀害了其中60人，用铁棒将她们活活打死，然后把她们的尸体扔进了宫殿的厕所里。所以各方表现都很糟糕，汤姆，我觉得这样说很公道。而巴黎的革命政府则给予了所有雅各宾派成员全面赦免。他们才是真正的受害者。
They're the real victims because the knitting needle action earlier on. So of course the French generally see them. I mean, this is the interesting thing. We in Britain, because of our own biases. We don't have biases, Dominic. No, you're right. Because of our objectivity. Because of our scrupulous objectivity.
他们才是真正的受害者，因为之前有织毛衣针事件。所以当然，法国人通常把他们视作……我的意思是，这就是有趣的地方。我们在英国，由于我们自身的偏见——我们没有偏见，多米尼克。不，你是对的。由于我们的客观性。由于我们一丝不苟的客观性，
We perceive the French Revolutionary Wars effectively as wars of French aggression, France exporting the gospel of revolution. Of course the French never perceive it that way. From the very beginning, they see themselves as you said, they are the victims. They think Varennes was a conspiracy, which it was, it was a betrayal. And all through France in this period, 1791, summer, autumn, there are endless rumours. I mean, there's a great one here of the Prés de Condé and the Comptte d'Artois are about to arrive with an army of men in black clothes made from the cassocks of... They'll be wearing like priests outfits from the cassocks of
我们实际上把法国大革命战争视为法国的侵略战争，是法国在输出革命的福音。当然，法国人从来不这么看。从一开始，他们就认为自己正如你所说的那样，他们是受害者。他们认为瓦雷纳事件是一场阴谋，事实也的确如此，这是一场背叛。在整个法国的这段时期——1791年的夏天、秋天，到处都充斥着无休止的谣言。我的意思是，这里有一个极好的谣言：孔代亲王和阿图瓦伯爵即将带着一支军队抵达，这支军队的人穿着黑色的衣服，衣服是用……他们会穿着类似神职人员的法衣，上面镶嵌着骷髅头。这非常类似于，你知道的，漫威超级反派之类的人物，正准备发动袭击。他们认为这一切的主谋——显然这位终极漫威超级反派——就是法国传统的敌人、奥地利皇帝，也就是利奥波德二世。
non-juring clergy studded with death's heads. It's very kind of like a, you know, Marvel super villains or something poised to attack. And the person who they think of this obviously the supreme Marvel super villain is France Francis traditional enemy, the Austrian emperor, so Leopold the second. Who's actually, I mean, not at all that. No, he's a lovely man. Like his brother Joseph, who we described earlier as essentially being a very kind of enlightenment figure.
而实际上，他根本不是那样的人。不，他是个可爱的人。就像他的兄弟约瑟夫一样，我们之前形容他基本上是一个非常具有启蒙运动色彩的人物。
And his plans for the church have been pretty identical to those of the revolution. It's just a question of who is framing these ideas. The rest is Habsburg history. Habsburg gets such a good press from us. Unbelievable. Where is the order of the golden fleece? We're still waiting. There's plenty wrong, but they are not the kind of the monstrous tyrants remotely. No.
他对教会的计划与革命者的计划几乎如出一辙。这只是一个由谁来阐述这些理念的问题。这就是哈布斯堡王朝的历史。哈布斯堡王朝从我们这里得到了如此高的评价。简直难以置信。金羊毛骑士团在哪里？我们还在等。这里有很多问题，但他们绝不是那种残暴的暴君。不。
No. Jacobin propaganda. So Leopold is Marie Antoinette's brother. He's sitting there in Vienna and has he intervened? No. Why hasn't he intervened? Actually because his empire has got its ructions of its own because of him and his brother Joseph's enlightened absolutism and his attempts to reform the church. Also because the Austrians are too busy fighting the Turks. There's all kinds of stuff kicking off in Poland. Poland is about to get partitioned. But also Leopold knows that Marie Antoinette is a bit of a head case. He doesn't think of her as a tremendous person. He actually thinks Marie Antoinette is a bit of a feckless waster.
不。雅各宾派的宣传。所以利奥波德是玛丽·安托瓦内特的兄弟。他坐在维也纳，他干预了吗？没有。他为什么没有干预？实际上是因为他的帝国自身也麻烦不断，这全拜他和他的兄弟约瑟夫的开明专制以及他对教会改革的尝试所赐。还因为奥地利人正忙于与土耳其人作战。波兰也发生着各种各样的乱子。波兰正面临被瓜分的命运。但利奥波德也知道玛丽·安托瓦内特脑子有点不太正常。他不认为她是一个了不起的人。他实际上觉得玛丽·安托瓦内特有点像个不负责任的败家子。
He obviously can't abandon her because she's his sister. So he's just kind of playing a waiting game. And actually what Leopold wants to do, he doesn't want a war, he wants to deter the French from as he sees it doing something stupid. Namely attacking him. Yeah. So in August 1791, he meets the King of Prussia, Frederick William II, at this castle, Pillnitz, in Saxony. The Count of Antoine is there as well, isn't he?
他显然不能抛弃她，因为她是他的妹妹。所以他只是在玩一场等待的游戏。实际上，利奥波德想做的是，他不想打仗，他只想阻止法国人去做他所认为的蠢事。也就是进攻他。是的。所以在1791年8月，他在萨克森的皮尔尼茨城堡会见了普鲁士国王腓特烈·威廉二世。阿图瓦伯爵也在场，对吧？
He's not invited. He's not actually invited. Is he not? No, he turns up uninvited. And he sits around outside. And they're like, oh God, that flipping loser is pitched up as well. So they issue a statement, the Kings of Austria and Prussia. And they say, look, the fate of the French King is a matter of concern
他没有被邀请。他其实根本没被邀请。是吗？没有，他不请自来了。他在外面闲逛。然后他们心想：“天哪，那个讨厌的失败者也凑过来了。”于是奥地利和普鲁士国王发表了一份声明。他们说，听着，法国国王的命运是
to all the sufferings of Europe. We want to see him enjoying his full libertism rights. Interesting. They're using the words, libertism rights. Right. And they say, they give a sort of hint that if it all kicks off in France and if all the monarchs of Europe agree, they would have to give serious consideration to further action or something like that.
全欧洲都关切的事。我们希望看到他享有其全部的自由权利。有趣的是。他们使用了“自由权利”这个词。没错。他们说，他们暗示说，如果法国局势彻底失控，并且如果欧洲所有君主都同意的话，他们将不得不认真考虑进一步的行动之类的事情。
To issuing a sternly worded dictat. It's very vague. And they think that this is like a little, just a little kind of warning to the French. Just calm down. It'll deter them, but it's clearly not a threat. They don't think that it's a threat to invade. Now the problem is that the Comte d'Artois, as you said Thomas, turned up and uninvited. He gets this statement, he has it printed from Koblenz and distributed across France with the cover letter in which
也就是发表一份措辞严厉的声明。这非常含糊。他们以为这只是一个小小的、对法国的警告。只要冷静下来就行。这会震慑住他们，但这显然不是一个威胁。他们并不认为这是一次入侵的威胁。现在的问题是，阿图瓦伯爵，正如你所说的那样，汤姆，他不请自来地出现了。他拿到了这份声明，让人在科布伦茨把它印出来，并在全法国分发，还附上了一封信，信中
he writes, the European monarchs are poised to invade. Lock up your daughters, we're on our way or whatever. With our death heads on. With our death heads. We're priests, cossacks. And of course, everybody in France says, oh my God, yet more proof of this hideous conspiracy. So that means that when Briceau, who we talked about in the first half, pornographer, hack
他写道，欧洲君主们已经准备好入侵了。锁好你们的女儿，我们正在路上，或者类似的话。带着我们的骷髅头。带着我们的骷髅头。我们是神职人员，穿着法衣。当然，法国的每个人都说：“哦天哪，这又是这起骇人听闻的阴谋的又一个证据！”所以这意味着，当布里索——我们在前半部分谈到过的人，色情作家、文人、
writer, travel writer, Tom loves him, abolitionist, great man for a literary salon, he stands up in October 1791 in the legislative assembly, he does have Vladimir Putin. He gives like an interminable lecture in which he says, France has been the victim of enemy expansion. We have been humiliated, not in the last few years, but in the last four decades. So since the beginning of the seven years war, we allied ourselves with Austria and Austria never delivered. They've cheated us. They've conspired against us.
旅行作家，汤姆很喜欢他，废奴主义者，文学沙龙的常客——当他在1791年10月起立在立法议会发言时，他简直就像弗拉基米尔·普京。他发表了一场没完没了的演讲，在演讲中他说，法国一直是敌人扩张的受害者。我们受到了羞辱，不是在过去几年里，而是在过去的四十年里。因此，自从七年战争开始以来，我们与奥地利结盟，而奥地利从未兑现承诺。他们欺骗了我们。他们密谋反对我们。
We have been the great victims in all world history, you know, and it's time for it to end. But Dominic, just to ask you, the focus of this is Vienna and not London. No, not London. It's really interesting. Because Britain really has been the most dangerous rival to France. But at this point, so William Pitt becomes a great hate figure in the 1790s in France, but I get the sense that it's a little bit later that all the rhetoric right now is about Austria. And I wonder how much of that is because they're seeing it all through the prism of the court of Marie Antoinette and her links to Austria. Massively, I would have thought. Yeah. Massively. That it's really remarkable reading all this stuff about it. The brilliant account of the
我们一直是世界历史上最大的受害者，你知道的，是时候结束这一切了。但是多米尼克，我想问你，这场风波的焦点是维也纳，而不是伦敦吗？不，不是伦敦。这真的很有趣。因为英国实际上一直是法国最危险的对手。但在此时，威廉·ピット（威廉·皮特）在1790年代的法国成了一个令人痛恨的人物，但我感觉这是稍微晚一点的事情，目前所有的言论都是关于奥地利的。我想知道其中有多少是因为他们都是通过玛丽·安托瓦内特宫廷以及她与奥地利的联系这一视角来看待这一切的。极大程度上，我是这么认为的。是的。极大程度上。阅读所有这些相关的资料真的非常引人注目。蒂莫西·塔凯关于恐怖统治到来的书中，对
road to war and Timothy Tackett's book about the coming of the terror. Britain, London are barely ever mentioned. It's all Vienna and Austria. I think that is genuinely because of the understanding of Marie Antoinette as an incestuous vampire at the heart of a great web of conspiracy. But that in itself reflects the fact that Austria for a long time has been France's traditional land enemy. And that in a way the French have often thought about Britain as a subsidiary, I mean the folly and hubris of it, Tom, as a secondary player, and they will learn.
通往战争之路的精彩描述中，英国和伦敦几乎从未被提及。全都是维也纳和奥地利。我认为这纯粹是因为人们将玛丽·安托瓦内特视为一个庞大阴谋网络核心的、带有乱伦色彩的女吸血鬼。但这也本身反映了一个事实，即奥地利长期以来一直是法国传统的陆地敌人。在某种程度上，法国人常常把英国视为一个附属——我的意思是，汤姆，这是何等的愚蠢和狂妄——视为一个次要角色，而他们将会吸取教训。
So Briceau says, look, it's very Putin-like. We need all these demands answering, he says. We seek redress, but he says they probably won't give us the redress, and that that's fine because war would be brilliant for us. First of all, he says, war will make us more united. It will restore our finances and public credit. It will put an end to terror, betrayals and anarchy. It would bring us, and I quote, domestic peace if we fight. Next he says, war will purge us of sin. Such a war is a sacred war, a war ordained from on high and like the heavens it will purify our souls. Extraordinary. War will make us more equal.
所以布里索说，看，这非常像普京。我们需要满足所有这些要求，他说。我们寻求补偿，但他接着说，他们可能不会给我们补偿，不过这没关系，因为战争对我们来说太棒了。首先，他说，战争会让我们更加团结。它将恢复我们的财政和公共信用。它将结束恐怖、背叛和无政府状态。如果我们开战，它会给我们带来——我引用一下——国内和平。接着他说，战争将洗涤我们的罪孽。这样的战争是一场圣战，一场上天注定的战争，它将像苍穹一样净化我们的灵魂。太不可思议了。战争将使我们更加平等。
Quote, by mixing men and ranks, elevating the plebeian, bringing down the proud patrician, war alone can make all equal and regenerate souls. Fascinating. He's using Roman terms there, ple Babians and Patricians. Exactly. And he actually then points, he says, finally, history shows that all free nations are defined by war. And he points to the examples of Republican Rome and the tax evaders and the American colonies. And he says, a people which has conquered its freedom after 12 centuries of slavery needs a war to consolidate it, to test itself, to show that it is worthy
引文：“通过将各阶层的人民融合在一起，提升平民的地位，打压傲慢的贵族，唯有战争才能使所有人平等并重塑灵魂。”太迷人了。他在那里使用了罗马术语，平民和贵族。完全正确。然后他实际上指出，最后，历史表明，所有自由的国家都是由战争定义的。他指出了罗马共和国、逃税者以及美洲殖民地的例子。他说，一个在经历了12世纪的奴役之后才赢得自由的民族，需要一场战争来巩固它，来考验它，来证明它是配得上
of freedom. So you see all the currents, the Republican Rome, the influence of America, the Christian mission. But again, that's what's so interesting is that he is, and this is what the French Revolution does so brilliantly, and Napoleon will as well, he fuses the idea of a civic culture, which is specific to the patrie, to France, with a sense of universalist mission. So France can go to war simultaneously, serving French interests, while also doing it on behalf of humanity. And what a brilliant fusion that is. I love all that because it's such a brilliant rhetorical sleight of hand. Briceau stands
自由的。所以你可以看到所有的思潮：罗马共和国、美国的影响、基督教的使命。但再次说明，最有趣的是，他——而这正是法国大革命所做得如此出色、拿破仑也同样会做的事情——他将一种特定于祖国（法兰西）的公民文化理念，与一种普世主义使命感融合在了一起。因此，法国可以同时发动战争，既服务于法国的利益，又代表全人类行事。这是多么精彩的融合啊。我喜欢所有这一切，因为这是一个如此高超的修辞把戏。布里索站在
there and he says, this is a crusade for universal liberty to free the enslaved peoples of Europe and topple all the former Bastille's. But at the same time, he says, by the way, the French are the foremost people of the universe and France is the model for the future of all mankind. So it's a brilliant trick to say nationalism is universalism. Because if we are the model, then by following our own national interest and conquering other countries, we're actually furthering the cause of liberty and isn't that lovely. So everyone loves that or do they?
那里说，这是一场争取普遍自由的十字军东征，旨在解放欧洲被奴役的人民并推翻所有的旧巴士底狱。但与此同时，他说，顺便说一句，法国人是宇宙中最优秀的民族，法国是全人类未来发展的模范。所以这是一个绝妙的把戏，把民族主义说成是普世主义。因为如果我们就是模范，那么通过追求我们自己的国家利益并征服其他国家，我们实际上是在推动自由事业的发展，这不是很好吗？所以每个人都喜欢这样，还是说并非如此？
Because the occasional person of principle who stands up and tells you that right? The Rob Spear fan cast. Maximilien Rob Spear has come back from Arras at the end of November 1791. Remember he's been away. He comes back and he gets an ecstatic reception at the Jacobin Club. And then he stands up in the Jacobin and he says, all this talk of war. Shocking.
因为总会有偶尔出现的有原则的人站出来告诉你这些，对吧？罗伯斯庇尔的粉丝团。马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔在1791年11月底从阿拉斯回来了。记住，他之前一直不在。他回来了，并在雅各宾俱乐部受到了热烈的欢迎。然后他在雅各宾派发表讲话，他说，所有这些关于战争的谈话。令人震惊。
I think war would be a terrible disaster. He's very prescient. I mean we said he's not a disaster. He's very prescient. I mean, we said he's not a fool. He really is prescient. He's really not wrong here because he talks about war risks the collapse of the revolution and threatens us with a Caesar, with a Cromwell. Yeah, he's absolutely right. I mean, he sees Bonaparte coming. And he also makes another very good point. He says, Briceau is saying explicitly, who loves America, is comparing this with the
我认为战争将是一场可怕的灾难。他非常有先见之明。我的意思是，我们说过他不是个笨蛋。他确实非常有先见之明。我的意思是，我们说过他不是个傻瓜。他确实极具先见之明。他在这里真的没有说错，因为他谈到战争有可能导致革命的崩溃，并威胁我们要迎来一个凯撒，迎来一个克伦威尔。是的，他绝对是对的。我的意思是，他预见了波拿巴的到来。而且他还提出了另一个非常好的观点。他说，布里索明确表示——他很喜欢美国——将这场战争与
American war of independence. He says, it's going to be nothing like the American war of independence. The Americans were fighting to preserve what they saw as their own liberties and their own native land. We would be fighting a war of expansion. He says it's the most extravagant idea that you can just waltz into someone's country and say, now you must adopt our laws. And I quote, nobody likes armed missionaries. You know, he'd be a brilliant guest on the
美国独立战争进行了比较。他说，这与美国独立战争完全是两码事。美国人是为了捍卫他们所认为的自由和自己的本土而战。而我们将要打的是一场扩张战争。他说，那种以为可以随随便便大摇大摆地走进别人的国家说“现在你们必须采用我们的法律”的想法，是最荒谬的想法。我引用一下：“没有人喜欢武装传教士。”你知道的，他会是《政治剩下的事》节目的一个绝佳嘉宾，
rest is politics. Wouldn't he Rob Spier? I'd love to hear him in debate with the hosts of the rest is party to discuss liberal interventionism, liberal interventionism. Then of course, Rob Spier being Rob Spier, there's a bit of a darkness there as well. He says to the Jacobin, the source of the evil is not in coblence. It is among you. It is in our midst. Let us overcome our enemies within and only then march against our foreign foes if any still exist. So in other words, it's not all kind of being shrewd. There's an element of the iron fist and the paranoid style. Rob Spier is still looking for the enemy within and saying, let's fight a war, but against our own neighbors in our own streets, not against people outside. Now, when Rob Spier does this, the Girondins are very shocked. Madame Rolland actually meets him privately
不是吗，罗伯斯庇尔？我很想听听他和《派对剩下的事》的主持人们进行辩论，讨论自由主义干涉主义，自由主义干涉主义。然后当然，罗伯斯庇尔毕竟是罗伯斯庇尔，其中也带有一丝黑暗色彩。他对雅各宾派说，罪恶的根源不在科布伦茨。它就在你们中间。它就在我们的心腹之中。让我们战胜内部的敌人，然后再去对抗我们的国外敌人——如果还有敌人存在的话。换句话说，这并不完全是出于精明。这里夹杂着铁腕统治和偏执狂风格的成分。罗伯斯庇尔仍在寻找内部的敌人，并表示：我们要打仗，但要跟我们自己的邻居、在我们自己的街道上打，而不是跟外面的人打。现在，当罗伯斯庇尔这样说时，吉伦特派感到非常震惊。罗兰夫人实际上私下会见了
and says, come on, you should be on board with us. We're all friends, be on our side. We're all Jacobin. And she fails and she writes to him after, I saw with pain that you are persuaded that any intelligent person who thinks differently from you about the war is not a good citizen. That's the key. Well, I mean, that sums up his character, isn't it? That does sum up his character, but it also sums up the politics for the next two years in France. You can't just disagree with somebody and, you know, fine, we'll agree. What do
他说：“得了吧，你应该和我们站在同一战线上。我们都是朋友，站在我们这边吧。我们都是雅各宾派。”但她失败了，她随后写信给他：“我痛苦地看到，你确信任何在战争问题上持有与你不同看法的聪明人都不是好公民。”这就是关键所在。好吧，我的意思是，这总结了他的性格，不是吗？这确实总结了他的性格，但也总结了接下来两年法国的政治局势。你不能仅仅与某人意见不一，然后（心想）“好吧，我们可以求同存异”。他们在《政治剩下的事》里是怎么说的？
they say on the rest is politics? We will disagree agreeably. There's none of that in the Legislative Assembly in France 1791-2. But also, crucially, there is no equivalent to His Majesty's loyal opposition. No. So there's no equivalent to His Majesty's loyal opposition. No. So there's no room for that. There's no room whatsoever. And actually, I also think there's a personal dimension. Rob Strayer had gone away and he came back and Briso was the big star and there was not
我们将愉快地求同存异。在1791-1792年的法国立法议会中，根本没有这种事。而且至关重要的是，这里没有“国王陛下的忠诚反对派”这一概念。没有。所以这里没有国王陛下的忠诚反对派的等同物。不。所以没有这个空间。毫无容身之地。实际上，我也认为这里面有个人层面的因素。罗伯斯庇尔曾经离开过，等他回来时，布里索已经成了大明星，而这里已经没有
room for both. This town ain't big enough for the both of us. You know, they're both proud men, but crucially, they both see themselves as the embodiment of virtue. And if somebody else is going around saying, actually, I'm the embodiment of virtue, then they've got to go. There's no sense, I guess, of moral or political pluralism. Well, also, I suppose what we'd recognise today as the modern party
他们两个人的容身之所了。这个小镇容不下我们俩。你知道的，他们都是骄傲的人，但至关重要的是，他们都视自己为美德的化身。如果另一个人四处宣扬“实际上我才是美德的化身”，那么其中一人就必须走人。我想，这里根本不存在道德或政治多元主义的概念。好吧，我也猜想，我们今天所认识的现代政党
system is in the process of being invented, but it hasn't yet reached the stage where the existence of one party led by one person doesn't serve as an automatic threat to someone else who wants to occupy that space. Yeah, I think there's no sense in which you can legitimately have more than one party or more than one faction. So the atmosphere becomes incredibly aggressive and polarized. You basically now have, we had before the Foyon and the Jacobin. What we have now is the Foyon, who are losing ground
制度正处于被发明的过程中，但它尚未发展到这样的阶段：由一个人领导的一个政党的存在，不会对另一个想要占据该空间的人构成直接的威胁。是的，我认为根本不存在可以合法拥有一个以上政党或一个以上派别的概念。因此，气氛变得异常好战和两极分化。你基本上拥有了——我们之前有斐扬派和雅各宾派。我们现在拥有的是斐扬派，他们一直在失势，他们算是老温和派。我的意思是，他们基本上要出局了。还有两个相互竞争的雅各宾派系，即吉伦特派，以及那些崇拜罗伯斯庇尔的人。现在他们坐在国民议会的高处，所以人们称他们为“山岳派”，他们被称为山岳党人。实际上，大多数时候当人们谈论你、当你想到恐怖统治和雅各宾派之类的事情时，人们想到的其实是山岳派。别忘了，这里面总是带有戏剧性和奇观的成分。
all the time, they're kind of old moderates. I mean, they're basically on the way out. And two rival Jacobin factions, so the Girondins, but also the people who admire Robespierre. Now they sit high up in the National Assembly, so people call them the Mountain and they become known as the Montagnards. So actually, most of the time when people are talking about you, when you think about the Reign of Terror and stuff and the Jacobin, it's the Montagnard faction that people are thinking about. And don't forget there's always an element of the theatrical and the spectacle about it.
旁听席上挤满了排队买票的普通民众，他们作为粉丝、作为参与者来到这里。因为女性也可以和男性一起出席，不是吗？她们在大喊大叫、欢呼、大声辱骂。人们开始携带武器，因为立法议会的议事大厅里爆发了类似虚拟斗殴的冲突。所以有一种强烈的解体感。现在，巴黎市外的事件一直在呼应这种氛围。对高物价和饥饿的愤怒依然存在。发生了所谓的“城堡之战”，农民们袭击乡村
The galleries are full of members of the public who would queue up for tickets and they're there as fans, as participants. Because women can attend as well as men, can't they? And they're shouting, they're cheering, throwing abuse. People start coming armed because there are kind of virtual brawls breaking out on the floor of the Legislative Assembly. So there's a real sense of a kind of disintegration. Now this is being echoed all the time by events outside Paris. Still a lot of anger about high prices and hunger. There's what's called a war on the chateau, peasants attacking country
宅邸，洗劫它们，烧毁果园。在巴黎郊外一个叫埃唐普的地方有一个例子，那里的市长在一次抢粮骚乱中被暴民处以私刑。他是雅各宾俱乐部的成员。你知道的，他是一个好革命者，但由于他试图强制推行许多议员所信奉的那种自由市场经济正义，民众调转枪头攻击了他，他们肢解了他的尸体。你知道的，这在巴黎引发了各种各样的焦虑。实际上，雅各宾派为了（试图）发出一些对稳定的呼吁，为他举办了一个法律节。现在罗伯斯庇尔，有趣的是，罗伯斯庇尔
houses, looting them, burning orchards. There's an example in a place called Etompe outside Paris, where the mayor ends up being lynched in a food riot. He's a member of the Jacobin club. You know, he's a good revolutionary, but because he's trying to enforce the kind of liberal free market orthodoxy that many of the kind of deputies have, the people turn on him, they mutilate his body. You know, this sets off all kinds of anxieties back in Paris. And actually the Jacobin organized a festival of law in his honor to try to, you know, make some plea for stability. Now Robespierre, interestingly, Robespierre
是一个如此出色的民粹主义者。他说：“什么？举办一个法律节来纪念一个人？这正说明了你们的问题，你们宁愿纪念一个大人物，也不愿关心挨饿的大众。”他的对手们一定恨死他了。是的，当然。他是一个……试图占据道德制高点，结果发现别人已经抢先一步占领了。是的。把他的旗帜插在了山顶。他非常像加图，不是吗？
is such a brilliant populist. He says, what? A festival of law to honor one man. That says it all about you, that you would rather honor one bigwig than care about the starving masses. His rivals must have hated him. Yeah, of course. He's a... Tried to seize the moral high ground only to find that he's got there first. Yeah. Planted his banner on the summit. He's very Kato, isn't he?
是的，他确实是。我想他是非常有意识地这样做的。你知道他是什么人吗？他简直是加图和托尼·本的结合体。他就像一个更加暴力的托尼·本。同样具有不可腐蚀性、道德苦行僧般的特质，但也带有那种激怒他同僚的民粹主义色彩——托尼·本在1970年代时也是如此。尽管据我所知，他没有被黄蜂蛰过生殖器。
Yeah, he is. Very self-consciously, I imagine. You know what he is? He's a cross between Kato and Tony Ben. He's like a much more violent Tony Ben. The same sense of incorruptibility, moral austerity, but also the populism that infuriates his own colleagues, which Tony Ben had in the 1970s. Although, so far as I'm aware, he didn't have his penis stung by a wasp.
托尼·本可被蛰过。是的。好事实，汤姆。好事实。我总是知道，每当我提到托尼·本的名字，你就会抖出那个我不知道的料。不管怎样，到了1791年底、1792年初，我猜法国政治越是碎片化，人们就越是认为只有战争才能将它弥合。所以到1791年底、1792年初，我猜法国政治越是碎片化，人们就越是认为只有战争才能将它弥合。
That's Tony Ben did. Yeah. Great fact, Tom. Great fact. I always know that whenever I mentioned Tony Ben's name, you'll bring out that, I don't know. Anyway, so by the end of 1791, 1792, I guess the more that French politics fragments, the more that people think that only a war can bring it together. So by the end of 1791, 1792, I guess the more that French politics fragments, the more that people think that only a war can bring it together.
有趣的是，除了罗伯斯庇尔之外，所有不同的派别和政治玩家都认为战争符合我個人的利益。因为他们抱持着不同的动机去这么想。是的。所以如果你是安托万·巴纳夫——上一集里的大明星——巴纳夫和他在斐扬派的朋友们，他们认为一场有限的战争符合我们的利益，因为法国注定会赢，而且国王按技术规定是总司令。所以每个人都会把功劳归于他。
And the interesting thing is that with the exception of Robespierre, all the different factions and players think a war will be in my personal interests. Because they all have different motivations for thinking that. Yeah. So if you're Antoine Barnard, who was the big star of the last episode, Barnard and his friends at the Foyon, they think a limited war will work in our favor because France is bound to win and the King is technically commander in chief. So everybody will give him credit.
国王万岁！耶！国王万岁！国王万岁！这将带来稳定。这显然是疯了。现在拉法耶特——我们这集还没提到拉法耶特呢，汤姆。我知道你很喜欢拉法耶特。
Hooray for the King! Yeah! Vive le Roi! Vive le Roi! And that'll bring stability. That's obviously madness. Now Lafayette, we haven't had any Lafayette in this episode yet, Tom. I know you love Lafayette.
但他是一位伟大而英勇的将军。所以他在战神广场大屠杀之后，曾参加巴黎市长竞选，结果惨败。真是忘恩负义。于是他气冲冲地隐退到了他在奥弗涅的乡间庄园。他心想：“哦，战争，太棒了！我喜欢战争。我知道怎么打仗。”他四处游说谋求指挥权，并说道：“太好了，莱茵河的一场小规模战争正合我意。我要在莱茵河打这场小战争。
But he's a great and dashing general. Well, so he, after the massacre at the Champs-D'Amars, he had stood in elections to be the mayor of Paris and he'd been absolutely hammered. Such ungratitude. And he'd gone off in a big sulk to his country estate in the Auvergne. And he thinks, oh, a war, brilliant. I love wars. I know how to run a war. He lobbies for command and he says, great, a little war in the Rhineland is just my cup of tea. I'll fight this little war in the Rhineland.
我显然会取得巨大的胜利。我会赢得所有的功劳，然后作为法国的英雄凯旋。”这就是拉法耶特支持战争的原因。令人难以置信的是，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特竟然也想要一场战争。玛丽·安托瓦内特当时在秘密与奥地利大使通信，她说：“啊，法国会在战争中遭到惨败。停战协议会瓦解，没钱，没纪律。”但她认为战争将非常棒，因为如果法国奇迹般地赢了，她认为她的丈夫将获得所有的功劳——顺便说一句，我觉得这简直是疯了。
I'll obviously win a massive victory. I'll get all the credit and I'll come back as the hero of France. So that's a lafayette for the war. The incredible thing is that Louis and Marie Antoinette want a war. Now Marie Antoinette was secretly communicating with the Austrian ambassador and she said, ah, France will get hammered in the war. The armistice will fall apart, there's no money, there's no discipline. But she thinks the war will be brilliant because if by a miracle France wins, she thinks her husband will get all the credit, which by the way, I think is bonkers.
但她认为合乎情理的是法国会输，然后奥地利人会开进巴黎，那将太棒了。她将在她的盛装下复辟。她可以嘲笑她所有的敌人。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。绝对疯狂。顺便说一句，她一直在给阿克塞尔·冯·菲尔森写信。他仍然在现场，她一直在给他写那些信。
But she thinks plausibly France will lose and then the Austrians will march into Paris and it'll be great. She'll be reinstalled in her pomp. She can laugh at all her enemies. I mean, it's bonkers. Absolutely bonkers. She's writing, by the way, to Axel von Fersen. He's still on the scene and she's sending him all those letters.
不过他在瑞典呢，不是吗？是的。她一直在说：“这会很棒的。这将是一场战争。我们会输，而我会笑到最后。”我觉得她给别人写信简直是疯了。她当然是疯了。我们一直相当——我认为按历史学家的标准来说，我们在第一季里对路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特相当
Well, he's off in Sweden though, isn't he? Yeah. And she's saying, it's going to be great. It's going to be a war. We'll lose and I'll be laughing. I think she's mad to be writing to people. Of course she is. We've been quite, I think, of the standards of historians, we were quite
同情。我认为在这个时候，他们的行为简直荒谬绝伦。他们缺乏常识的程度令人匪夷所思。我的意思是，对于一个国王和王后来说，煽动针对自己人民的战争没有什么比这更犯罪的了。路易正在给流亡者写信说，我引用一下：“现在是欧洲主要大国召开会议入侵法国的时候了。这是确保困扰我们的灾难不会蔓延到欧洲其他国家的唯一方法。”
sympathetic to Louis and Meryn Twinnett in the first season. I think at this point they are behaving ludicrously. Their lack of common sense is mind-boggling. I mean, nothing could be more criminal than for a king and queen to encourage war against their own people. Louis is writing letters to the emigres saying, and I quote, it is time for a congress of the principal powers of Europe to invade France. This is the only way of ensuring the evils which beset us to not spread to the other
我想不出历史上有多少其他例子，一个君主煽动他的敌人攻击他自己的国家，希望他自己的国民被打败和杀死，而他自己将……我的意思是，这太疯狂了。剧透一下，我们将以处决国王来结束这个系列、这个季节。我想说他罪证确凿。我的意思是，他显然背叛了国家。是的。
states of Europe. I can't think of many other examples in history of a monarch inciting his enemies to attack his own country in the hope that his own people will be defeated and killed and he will... I mean, that's mad. Spoiler alert, we're going to end this series, this season with the execution of the king. And I would say he's bang to rise. I mean, he clearly has betrayed the country. Yeah.
他犯了叛国罪。我的意思是，你没有说错。我无法反驳。所以我们来到了1792年1月。有一种强烈的宿命感。流亡王子们最终被宣布为叛国者，他们的土地被没收。然后在整个1月份，你开始了这一集的节目，汤姆，朗读了皮埃尔·韦尼奥那篇非凡的演讲——拿起武器。这里有很多类似的内容。我的意思是，布里索在立法议会里说：这将是一场争取普遍自由的十字军东征。每个士兵都会对他的敌人说：“兄弟，我不是来割你的喉咙的。我是来给你指明通往幸福的道路的。”我的意思是，
He is guilty of treason. I mean, you're not wrong. I can't disagree with it. So we get to January 1792. There's a real sense of inevitability. The emigre princes are finally declared traitors and their lands are declared forfeit. And then all that month in January, you began this episode Tom, reading that extraordinary speech by Pierre Vianio to arms. There's loads of this stuff. I mean, Briceau is there in the Legislative Assembly. This will be a crusade for universal liberty. Every soldier will say to his enemy, brother, I am not going to cut your throat. I'm going to show you the way to happiness. I mean,
他们竟然能说出这种话，而人们则在泣不成声、挥舞着帽子、互相拥抱，做着所有这些类似的事情，这太疯狂了。1792年1月14日发生了这样一幕：他们全体举起手臂宣誓：我将誓死捍卫法国宪法，对抗欧洲的敌人。他们基本上是在重演网球场宣誓。但当时的人们说，这是一个比网球场宣誓更令人振奋、更激动人心的时刻。于是他们向维也纳发出通牒，在1月底同意向维也纳发送通牒。利奥波德必须切断他与流亡者的所有关系。他曾承诺永远不与法国的敌人结盟，等等诸如此类的事情。接着是数周的谈判。
it's crazy that they're coming out with this and people are sobbing, waving their hats, embracing all of this kind of stuff. There's this scene on the 14th of January 1792 where they all raise their arms and swear an oath. I would defend to the death the French constitution against the enemies of Europe. They're basically reenacting the Tennis Court oath. But people said at the time it was an even more rousing and exciting moment than the Tennis Court oath. So they send Vienna, they agree at the end of January to send Vienna and ultimate him. Leopold must break off all his relations with the exiles. He was promised he'll never ally with the enemy of France, all of this kind of stuff. Now there's then weeks of negotiations.
法国人最终给了奥地利人直到3月1日的期限。他们说，我们必须在3月1日得到答复。在3月1日，利奥波德不幸突然驾崩了。哦天哪，这时间太不巧了。他在3月1日——3月1日这天。利奥波德不幸突然驾崩。哦天哪。这时间太不巧了。这真是太不巧了。或者也许是个好时机。好吧，是的，他的儿子弗朗西斯二世继位了。他非常年轻，实际上他的顾问比他父亲的顾问更年轻。
The French had given the Austrians until the 1st of March, eventually. They said, we must have a reply on the 1st of March. On the 1st of March, Leopold, unfortunately, drops dead. Oh dear, that's bad timing. He is first to March on the first to March. Leopold, unfortunately drops dead. Oh dear. That's bad timing. He is very bad timing. Or maybe good timing. Well, yeah, he is succeeded by his son, Francis the second. He's very young and actually he's got younger advisors than his father.
这些顾问说：“好极了，跟法国人干吧。来吧。这是开启你统治的绝佳方式。法国人现在一团糟。跟他们打一仗吧。”玛丽·安托瓦内特难道没有把法国的计划送出去吗？她送了。她一直在秘密地将法国的军事计划发送给奥地利人。我在第一季里说过，我同情路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特，但这就是疯狂。
And the advisors say, yeah, let's get it on with the French. Come on. This is a brilliant way to start your reign. The French are in an absolute shambles. Let's have a war with them. Hasn't Marie Antoinette sent the French plans? She has. She has secretly been sending the French military plans to the Austrians. I said in season one, I felt sorry for Louis and Marie Antoinette, but this is madness.
在这一切发生之前，法国发生了一个戏剧性的发展。我们在这个播客里最喜欢法国发生戏剧性的发展了。路易一直有权拥有自己的大臣。所以他选择自己的大臣，而不是由立法议会选择。他的大臣们是温和派、斐扬派。但在1792年3月中旬，吉伦特派基本上发动了一场政治政变。他们搞到了一堆泄露的信件并宣读了这些信件，这些信件让路易的大臣们看起来简直是绝对的懦夫和马屁精，对奥地利人软弱可欺，诸如此类。因此路易最终不得不任命了一个吉伦特派的战争内阁。其中，有一个人是大家应该记住的，那就是新任外交大臣，
Now before all this happens, there's a dramatic development in France. We love a dramatic development in France on this podcast. Louis always had the right to have his own ministers. So he chose his ministers, not the legislative assembly. His ministers were moderates, foils. But in the middle of March 1792, the Girondins basically organized a political coup. They got hold of a load of leaked letters and they read them out that made it look like Louis' ministers were just absolute weaklings and lickspittles and soft on the Austrians and all this. And Louis therefore had to end up appointing a Girondin war ministry. Among them, the one person that people should get in their heads is the new foreign minister
因为他将是一个非常重要的人物。他叫迪穆里埃。他五十多岁。他是一个老兵，是拉法耶特的好朋友。他是一个饱经沧桑、严肃认真的人，一个军人。他的战争履历中其实有一个讽刺之处，不是吗？因为他曾服役于开进科西嘉岛的法国军队。他在那里执行过间谍任务，并在那里服役了两个战役。而这当然会导致拿破仑·波拿巴成为
because he will be a very important person. He's called Dumouriez. He's in his mid-fifties. He is a war veteran, his great friend of Lafayette. He's a kind of grizzled, serious person, a military man. And there's an irony to his war record, isn't there? Because he'd actually served in the French army that went in the next Corsica. He'd been on spying missions there and then he served two campaigns there. And this of course is what will result in Napoleon Bonaparte becoming
法国军队的军官。确实如此。这很有名，汤姆。是的。这是一个好点子。迪穆里埃，他来自比利时边境附近。他曾担任现在被称为比利时的革命者的军事顾问。作为外交大臣，他对立法议会说：
an officer in the French army. That's true. It's well noted, Tom. Yeah. It's a good point. Du Maurier, he came from near the Belgian border. He had been a military advisor to revolutionaries in what's now Belgium. And he, as foreign minister, he says to the legislative assembly,
“嘿，解放比利时的战争将轻而易举。比利时人迫不及待地想从奥地利人手中被解救出来，不再成为奥地利属尼德兰。只要我们一过境，他们就会奋起反抗。在人类事务中，从来没有比我们战胜奥地利人更确定的胜利了。这绝对会非常精彩。”与此同时，奥地利人——他们并不像迪穆里埃所认为的那样完全是一群小丑——正向比利时派遣数以万计的军队。
Hey, a war to liberate Belgium would be an absolute cakewalk. The Belgians are gagging to be rescued from the Austrians, to no longer be the Austrian Netherlands. They will rise as soon as we cross the border. There's never been a more certain victory in human affairs than our victory against the Austrians. It'll be absolutely brilliant. The Austrians, meanwhile, who are not complete clowns as Duméryé seems to think, are sending tens of thousands of troops to the Belgian
嘿，一场解放比利时的战争将是一场绝对轻而易举的胜利。比利时人急切盼望从奥地利人手中被拯救出来，不再成为奥地利属尼德兰。只要我们一过境，他们就会奋起反抗。在人类事务中，从来没有比我们对奥地利人的胜利更确定的胜利了。这绝对会非常精彩。与此同时，奥地利人并没有像迪穆里埃想象的那样全是一群小丑，他们正向比利时派遣数万名军队
frontier because they're looking forward to Kate Walker of their own. So on the 20th of April, the moment comes. Louis goes to the Legislative Assembly, Duméryé stands up to give this speech and Duméryé says, right, again, it's very Vladimir Putin. He says, ever since 1756, we have actually been enslaved by Austria. The House of Austria has enslaved France to its selfish ambition. We've asked for a redress and they've given us none. We will rip up our treaty with Austria and go to war and this will be an act of joyful destruction. It'll be just like the fall of the Bastille actually. It'll be brilliant. Yeah. People being torn to pieces and heads sprayed on pikes.
因为他们都在期待属于自己的凯特·沃克。因此，在4月20日，时刻来临了。路易来到立法议会，迪穆里埃起立发表这篇演讲，迪穆里埃说，对，再次强调，这非常像弗拉基米尔·普京。他说，自1756年以来，我们实际上一直被奥地利奴役。奥地利王室为了其自私的野心奴役了法国。我们要求纠正，而他们什么也没有给我们。我们要撕毁与奥地利的正统条约并开战，这将是一场欢乐的毁灭行动。实际上，这就像巴士底狱的陷落一样。这太棒了。是的。人们被撕成碎片，头颅挂在长矛上。
And one or two deputies, Tom, have some sense. So there's a moderate guy called Louis Bacquet, who says, I don't know about this, we shall be portrayed as aggressors. We will be portrayed as a disorderly country that upsets the peace of Europe in defiance of treaties and our own laws. Of course, that is how they are going to be portrayed for the next quarter of a century. And indeed, you could argue in Anglo-Saxon historiography for the next 300 years or whatever. But they all vote for this declaration of war. And then Louis is given the declaration to be read out. Now Now there's a slight problem with the declaration. The National Assembly had explicitly declared that France had renounced wars of conquest and aggression, and they would never again go to war against anybody
汤姆，有一两个代议士还有点理智。所以有一个温和派叫路易·巴凯，他说，我不知道这行不行，我们会把我们描绘成侵略者。我们会把自己描绘成一个扰乱欧洲和平、无视条约和我们自己法律的混乱国家。当然，在接下来的四分之一世纪里，他们确实就是这样被描绘的。事实上，你甚至可以说在盎格鲁-撒克逊史学中，在接下来的300年或更长时间里也是如此。但他们都投票赞成这项宣战声明。然后路易被交予这份宣战声明并宣读。现在，这份声明有一个小问题。国民议会曾明确宣布，法国已经放弃了征服和侵略战争，他们将永不再与任何人开战
and free people. So the declaration says, well, actually we've been attacked, so it's fine. Kind of. Yeah. It's a defensive war. It looks like we're invading other countries, but actually it's a completely defensive war against the unjust aggression of the Austrians. We're going in to kick out Nazis. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So Louis reads this out in this very quiet, stammering voice, because I think
以及自由的人民。所以声明说，嗯，实际上我们受到了攻击，所以没关系。算是吧。这是一场防御战。看起来我们在入侵其他国家，但实际上这是一场完全针对奥地利人不公正侵略的防御战。我们要进去赶走纳粹。对，没错。对，没错。所以路易用这种非常平静、结结巴巴的声音读了这段话，因为我认为
even though he said he's all for it, he realises now this is a moment of maximum danger for him. And everybody cheers, there are people crying with joy. I mean, it is very unlike the previous war we did on this podcast, the Great War, where people- They're nervous, aren't they? And hesitant. Yeah, there's a sense of terrible foreboding. Exactly. There was none of that in Paris in 1792. And of course, I think there are a few moments in world history that are more replete with irony because first of all, Rob Spare was totally right. There is going to be the rise of a Caesar of a dimension that they cannot even
尽管他说他完全赞成，但他现在意识到这对他是极度危险的时刻。所有人都欢呼雀跃，有人喜极而泣。我的意思是，这与我们在本播客中做过的前一场战争——大战——截然不同，那场战争中人们——他们很紧张，对吧？而且犹豫不决。是的，有一种可怕的预感。完全没有。1792年的巴黎完全没有这种气氛。当然，我认为世界历史上很少有哪个时刻比这更充满讽刺意味，因为首先，罗伯斯庇尔完全是对的。将会有一个他们在这个阶段甚至无法想象其规模的凯撒崛起
conceive of at this point, meaning Napoleon. But also when I finished writing the notes for this, I look back at every human being that I mentioned in the course of the episode. They all die. So Louis, Marie Antoinette, Briceau, Vergnio, Barnard, Madame Roulon, even Rob Spear, they will be on their way out. And of course, they will all perish as way out. And of course they will all perish as a result of the same identical instrument of execution, which for many people, particularly in the English speaking
这就是拿破仑。但当我写完这集的笔记时，我回顾了我在这一集过程中提到的每一个人类。他们都死了。所以路易、玛丽·安托瓦内特、布里索、韦尼奥、巴纳夫、罗兰夫人，甚至罗伯斯庇尔，他们都将在劫难逃。当然，他们都会作为代价而消亡。当然，他们都会死于同一种处决工具，对于许多人，特别是在英语世界里，这种工具已经真正成为了法国大革命的象征，不是吗？那就是断头台。所以你经常会发现，我的意思是，我们很可能会把我们接下来的那一集叫做“断头台的阴影”，因为这将是我们下一集的主题。我们将暂时从政治叙事中脱身，来看看断头台这个革命尤其是恐怖统治的伟大象征是如何被发明的，以及它如何在我们将要讲述的随后的政治叙事中发挥作用
world has really become the symbol of the French revolution, hasn't it? And that is the guillotine. So you will often get, I mean, we may well call our subsequent episode, the shadow of the guillotine, because that is going to be the subject of our next episode. And we'll be taking a slight break from the political narrative, just to look at how it is that the guillotine, this great symbol of the revolution and particularly of the terror, how it comes to be invented and how it comes to play the role
这就是断头台。所以你经常会发现，我的意思是，我们很可能会把我们接下来的那一集叫做“断头台的阴影”，因为这将是我们下一集的主题。我们将暂时从政治叙事中脱身，来看看断头台这个革命尤其是恐怖统治的伟大象征是如何被发明的，以及它如何在我们将要讲述的随后的政治叙事中发挥作用
that it will in the subsequent political narrative that we'll be telling. How it is that all these people end up dead as a result of its slicing blade. So we have that to look forward to the coming of the guillotine. Of course, if you want to hear that episode now, you can join our very own group of... Gérardin? Yeah, our very own faction at The Rest Is History Club at therestishistory.com, but if not, we'll be back and Tom will be bringing down the guillotine. Au revoir.
所有这些人最终都死于它的利刃之下。所以我们可以期待断头台的到来。当然，如果你现在就想听到那一集，你可以加入我们自己的……热拉尔派？是的，加入我们在 therestishistory.com 的“历史就是一切”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）我们自己的派系，但如果没有，我们会回来的，汤姆将放下断头台。再见。
Au revoir. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。